foreign
good morning everyone welcome to house
environment agriculture committee
I'd like to take a moment stand up and
take the Pledge of Allegiance before we
I pledge allegiance
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you
so this morning we have
a list a couple of bills and we are
going to start off with HB the hearing
for HB 300
and I invite representative Ebel to come
up and introduce this bill so I'm
opening the hearing for house bill 300.
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is Karen Ebel I
represent Merrimack District 7 and that
is Newbury and New London
I'm here to introduce
HB 300 which would prohibit the disposal
of certain food waste
um
it's a fairly straightforward Bill uh
basically what it says is that any
person which would include
businesses of course as it's defined
that generates one ton of food waste per
week or greater can't dispose of that
food waste in a landfill or incinerator
as long as there is an alternative
facility with the capacity to accept the
food waste within 50 miles
the order of preference and how you
would dispose of the food waste
basically reflects the um the food
resource higher hierarchy which is you
want to try to get most of it that you
can to humans before you actually
dispose of it so for any business that
is having to
uh
use an alternative form of getting their
food waste as opposed to land filling it
they have the Alternatives of of using
food banks
farms and also of course composting
facilities
so in conversations with the chair
um I did suggest that
in the course of introducing this bill I
would kind of give a history of where we
are in the state as far as solid waste
because actually I was thinking about it
as I was driving down here today we've
really come a long way since 2019 and I
want to uh when a lot of this started
with a legislative study committee that
I chaired that was looking pretty deeply
into Recycling and solid waste issues
and that was prompted by the China
national sword policy in which they said
that they weren't
um going to take a lot of our plastic
and mixed paper anymore and so a lot of
our towns were floundering and that's
what initiated the interest in the study
committee
that was in uh late 2019 and I really I
want to thank the committee very much
for all the support that it's given and
the support the Des has provided
um in really trying to pull the state
out of kind of the Dark Ages as far as
Solid Waste Management is concerned
I think uh where a lot of us may be
frustrated that we haven't made more
progress but I really I I and I put a
lot of hyperlinks in the testimony that
was submitted online and I want to go
through this just briefly for you
because this is what we have done and
I I think we should all be proud of the
work that's been accomplished the first
thing we did was we updated our Solid
Waste diversion goals the diversion
goals that were on the books on the
statute went back to 2000 and nothing
had been updated since and needless to
say we hadn't achieved them our
diversion goals now are we want to
divert by weight 25 percent of what's
landfilled or incinerated by 2030 and
we're shooting for 45 percent by 2050.
one of the huge things that's happened
is that we've issued a solid waste
management plan a long-range plan this
plan had not been updated since 2003.
this took a lot of work on the part of
the department and I'm really proud of
the product that we have put forth
we also created the solid waste working
group which I chair which was
specifically tasked to work with des and
the development of the plan but also to
help move the state forward
in general to to do better with our
solid waste the solid waste working
group is a stakeholder group it includes
representatives of public and private
landfills
smaller towns bigger cities we have
someone from the business and economic
Administration Bea I we really try to
someone from unh
so we really tried to put together a
group that was representative of the
state
in addition uh Des which had been the
especially the solid waste Bureau had
been severely underfunded for the last
20 or 30 years due to budget cuts
and it was very difficult for them to do
any planning and part of the problem
that we have had is that Des
hasn't been able to surprise to provide
any sort of planning or other support
it's been difficult for them to our
towns and to our businesses so when you
have a situation like what happened with
national with the national sword policy
with the Chinese all of a sudden the
towns are floundering and this is a
Global Market at the same time as this
is an intensely personal and local issue
this is a global issue that affects so
many people in so many ways and clearly
economic and Des the planning department
that they once had had been wiped out so
I'm really happy to say that there has
been some more funding at the state
level to allow them to add a little you
know some more staff but they've created
a planning department again which we
haven't had in decades and there's two
folks here
there the department is small but it's
mighty and I just want to give them Mike
Nork and Paige Wilson a shout out
because they've got a lot of heart and
they've really been unbelievably helpful
through this whole process especially
Mike because when I started I didn't
know what MSW or a Murph was or anything
so lots of uh lots of acronyms the
second thing that we did I mean the last
one other thing that we did we've
created the solid waste management fund
that is a fund that would establish a
matching grant program for towns and
businesses to do better with their
infrastructure and their Solid Waste
diversion methods and
although it's not funded at this point
and we'll hear about enough we'll hear
another bill later today where we'll
talk more about the funding this is
really a critical piece of our
um overall umbrella policy to get our
state back in the game and moving
forward again we are so behind from a
regional standpoint other states are
very aggressively working to promote
recycling
composting you know uh and basically
Banning more and more things from going
into landfills and they're progressively
closing down their landfills if you read
the uh Globe article front page of the
Sunday magazine you know that
Massachusetts is shutting down its
landfills and we're sitting here with
ours and needless to say
we're getting a lot of trash that isn't
going to other places in other states
so this particular measure is a really
big opportunity for us to step out of
the planning stage and into the action
stage I've had more people say they're
really concerned that we've come this
far we've got our plan in place but
we're not going to do anything to make
it happen
so this uh the based on on the research
that the solid waste working group did
we decided to recommend legislation that
would focus very clearly on uh food
waste you'll hear more about it I'm sure
but 25 percent of weight according to
the EPA that goes into landfills is food
waste we can do a tremendous amount of
good if we start the way we've suggested
here focusing on large generators of
food waste and and that way we can do
better
um it is a chicken and egg issue you
need infrastructure to receive the food
waste but if you're going to be putting
you know collecting your food waste you
also want to
um have some place to put it it's uh
I've talked to other states they said it
actually marries really well because if
businesses know that food waste has to
be
um just gotten rid of in different ways
they'll start to develop uh businesses
to receive that food waste and I've
talked to several smaller businesses
that are really excited to hear about
this
um
there are also Food Bank folks food
insecurity folks that are super excited
to hear about this because they're
looking forward to getting more food to
feed the hungry which of course is what
a lot of this is all about
um
and the only other thing I I just want
to comment that there is a fiscal note
on this I I just like to encourage the
um
encourage the committee to focus on the
policy aspect of this because many
policy bills if we adopt the policy it's
sent over to finance to talk about the
um the financial aspect of it
and
I just want to say again let's not let
our plans uh sit on the shelf and gather
dust I'm not sure if he's been able to
get here yet but Henry veyer was going
to be here from Waste Management if you
had any questions for him he'd be happy
to um answer that
and with that I'll see if the committee
has any questions thank you thank you
representative evil
any questions from the committee
representative
thank you madam Sharon thank you for
taking my question
um during your testimony you mentioned
uh that Farms could be a possible source
of taking the food waste have we updated
our compost laws uh for that
well
in in the process of uh trotting out all
the exciting things that we've done I
would say that uh the other thing that's
really exciting that we've done is we've
updated our composting Rigs and Mr Nork
is here if you want to hear more about
that he can tell you
the main thing was to try to sort of
loosen up a little bit on on the
regulations that apply to taking compost
and one small comp smaller composting
business I know is working with our town
they actually take it to a farm in Derry
and when we were doing our study
committee
hearings there was interest in the
agricultural Community when they came to
testify because they were looking
forward to being able to do more
composting on site in addition to their
thank you any other questions from the
committee representative Dotsy
oh thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um I have uh how did you decide on one
ton and 50 miles and can you quantify
a one ton in terms of who would is that
restaurant it's hard for me to
understand a ton of food a week just
seems like a lot it does seem like a lot
but if you've if you compost and you lug
your bags to the transfer station you'll
be amazed at how much less your bags
weigh if you don't have food waste in
them anyway
um okay so basically in deciding which
way to go on the legislation we looked
at what our neighboring states were
doing across the Northeast and
um virtually every one of them started
with the one ton per week measurement
and that just seemed reasonable but like
you I had a hard time sort of
envisioning it so I actually talked to
someone in the business yesterday agric
agricycle because they collect they
collect this and they take they take the
food waste to Maine where they produce
energy with it which a whole is a whole
nother aspect that you know I haven't
really talked that much about
so he told me that if you have 64 gallon
totes which is how a lot of this stuff
is collected
each tote depending on how closely you
pack it is 200 to
so you multiply that out and he said
that's eight to ten tons a week
eight to ten totes a week which makes a
ton right so as far as the 50 miles
um I'm
I I be I'd encourage the committee not
to get really hung up on the 50 miles if
the committee is interested in doing
something like this which I really hope
you are
um you know you can think about the
mileage a lot of states have used 20.
Massachusetts used zero so I just went
part way in between
um the 50-mile radius of course doesn't
just apply to composting facilities it
applies to food banks it would apply to
Farms you know I think a lot of those
things could very well be within the
50-mile radius but
um looking at models from other states
it is true that many of them use the one
ton and 20 mile as opposed to the larger
number that I've chosen and as I said
before Massachusetts had
um zero
so
thank you um representative smart you
have a question
thank you madam chair I think I have a
question
um
there's regulations for or appears to be
regulations for out date and sell by
dates on foods and you talk about giving
it to the needy or hungry how do you get
around that
um because I
I have a small farm and we've approached
grocery stores and and various
retail
to get their what they're throwing away
because it goes by sell by
um and we've been told they're not
allowed to sell it to us or give it to
us because
um
uh we if we ate it and we got sick we
could sue them uh so they're not
releasing any of that is there anything
about
um
how to get around that or relaxing that
law are we removing sell by dates what's
um
when we were working
with our
hb617 study committee one of the things
that we actually wanted to focus on was
food food safety regulations to see you
know as you say if you if you want to
get food to the hungry
that's a that's an issue and they're
they're important but you also don't
want to overdo it
um
unfortunately because of covid the study
committee that I had put in a bill uh to
study this stuff went went sideways and
so that has not been done it's something
I think we'll go we'll be talking about
at the working group
I have heard of this issue I'm hoping
that there's someone here from the food
um you know bank group that can talk a
little bit about the sell-by dates but I
did have a pretty long conversation with
someone at Hannaford actually and you
know they freeze the meat they work very
seamlessly with folks from the food
banks that come in and get it and my
impression is that maybe the sell-by
date
doesn't have to be is here to as much by
the food banks but
um it's it's a really important question
and um I'm hoping there's someone here
that might have more information on that
thank you any other questions from the
committee for representative evil
representative datsey
uh thank you uh who the way this bill is
written who do you feel is going to be
most affected by it what what types of
businesses
um I looked into that a little bit and I
talked to some folks from from other
states
hospitals perhaps
um grocery stores food processors folks
like that very large restaurants I don't
I mean I'm not sure restaurants would be
particularly affected
I I will say that I think that
a lot of larger institutions are very
interested in doing something better
with their waste not just food waste
they're already having to deal with the
food waste in one way this is just
another sort of recyclable that has to
be separated in a different way you know
they still have to pay tipping fees for
the wait whether it's being separated or
not separated and you know it's it's
again sort of this chicken and egg issue
I mean you want to make sure that
there's the infrastructure to to support
um the amount of food waste that would
come down
and I would just reiterate you know we
have a plan now we want to do better
with what we're doing with solid waste
this is a great first step from a from a
policy standpoint and and you know if we
want to divert food from our landfills I
think this is the way to go and one
thing that I didn't mention is food in
landfills also produces
methane which is like a horrible
greenhouse gas as it as it starts to
dispose to degrade so that's another
savings and then of course there's the
energy piece but anyway I digress
thank you representative Howard
thank you madam chair um I was going to
ask you about methane because doesn't
composting also produce methane
okay so another thing that I've learned
um in landfills it's an anaerobic
atmosphere so there's not a lot of
oxygenation and there's actually not a
huge despite what a lot of people may
believe there's actually not a huge
amount of degradation that goes into
land that happens in landfills so if you
landfill something
it's really not going anywhere any
degradation that occurs is um
you know
there's like a daily cover I know Mike
Nork is really proud of me
there's daily cover that's like soil
over the top of the landfill and the
water when it rains it can percolate
through and that's what starts some of
the degradation and that's what ends up
and you're really nauseous landfill
leachate
so it produces methane in that anaerobic
non-oxygenated situation but when you do
it out in the open air it's not
generating the methane
I was worried about that myself
representative Bixby
yes thank you for taking my question uh
so is there a uh procedure for how the
amount of food waste that's being
produced and diverted is going to be
tracked and measured
I would ask that of the department if
this policy is
um just I just want to say that if this
policy is adopted which again I really
hope it is
the agency obviously would have to come
up with some sort of regulation for
administration of it follow up follow up
so does the does the bill have
rulemaking authority uh for that purpose
in it
um under 149 M the agency is authorized
to implement regulations thank you um I
just want to make a note on the
measurement I had some concern on how
you figure out how much a ton is there's
also new MOA food estimators which
according to representatives of the
agencies that administer these programs
in other states they tend they use the
estimators as well
thank you thank you
representative Creighton
thank you madam chair
yeah
applaud the idea I just don't understand
exactly if I'm a grocer
say I'm the manager of Shaw's and I got
1.5 tons of
expired food
what exactly do I do with that 1.5 times
I can't take it to them now
what do I do with it
well first of all if there's uh
facility that has adequate capacity you
can reach out to food banks or whatever
within the hierarchy to try to get rid
of your your food waste you obviously
have to isolate it in some way and
honestly I think many Grocers are trying
to do this sort of thing
one of the concerns so let's let's talk
about uh agricycle which happens to be
the group that I spoke to yesterday they
have a contract with Hannaford's and
they bring totes to Hannaford 64 gallon
totes and the manager at Hannaford said
they just put all their food waste into
these totes and agricycle actually has a
mechanism whereby the food can be
depackaged so if you have like tomatoes
in a package or strawberries they have
they have machine that can take them all
apart and then put them into the
digester so according to the manager
that I went to because I wanted to
understand like you practically how this
works he said they just dump everything
into these totes packages everything
agricycle comes through once a week they
dump the totes into their
thingy the collecting truck they put the
totes back down on the landing dock the
people at Hannaford spray them out and
then they just start all over again
does that answer your question I'm going
to follow up now go ahead follow up okay
and so what about for example you
mentioned hospitals so most of that
waste is going to be stuff that the
patients don't eat it's just play
scrapings
how does does that work the same way
I will admit that I didn't talk to a
hospital I had intended to but I didn't
get that far I mean they just a lot of
it also comes in cafeterias I think they
would just scrape the uh the food into
uh into
um uh you know collection location I
will say that we have a representative
uh of the health care industry on the
working group because I thought it would
be really important to have their uh
voice and you know we reach consensus on
that bill and and she didn't vote uh
raise particular concerns okay I'm sorry
one one follow one more one more go
ahead
and so last last question is so I'm I'm
the grocer I get or or whoever and I
only can get rid of one ton I still got
half a ton left
what happens with that other half the
time I guess whatever you do with the
rest of your waste you probably take it
to the landfill I mean I think this is
the and I thought we prohibited the land
no no so this is the this is the trick
here the trick is that if you have an
alternative facility that has adequate
capacity then you're required to use
that facility just dispose of the waste
if there's not a facility either within
the whatever we decide you decide is the
parameter
and those facilities can't take your
waste then you just do with it whatever
you would have done with it otherwise so
I've heard somebody call this like a
field of dreams I mean you're setting up
a scenario where you know you you have
the waste if there's a facility
available to take it then you are
required to get rid of it and then if
there's not then you're not
okay thank you very much ma'am sure
representative
thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question
you've spoken a lot about the group
agricycle
um
and it seems to me from just hearing you
talk about them they're picking up from
different Hannafords and taking it to
Maine correct okay
however if they're taking it to Maine in
your in say Lebanon New Hampshire that's
more than 50 miles correct so how would
that uh work because if we're limiting
okay we're not limiting the mileage on
where the food can go what we're doing
is if you're if you're in Lebanon an
agricycle is here and it's 150 miles
away
you know there may be other places
besides the agricycle well let's just
say we only have agricycle you're under
no uh duty to have to bring your food to
agricycle however
um you know if you make like Hannaford I
guess throughout the Northeast has a
relationship with agricycle and they
just come and they pick it up and then
they bring it to Maine that's just the
way it works for them
um I don't know if that but but as I say
the the limitation is you don't have to
get rid of your waste if there's not a
place for you to do it within 50 miles
or 20 or 30. as I said in Maine I mean
in Massachusetts they had no limitation
at all
follow-up uh thank you madam chair
um the other question I have is is say
there is something within the 50 mile
radius that would like this food waste
um but agricycle who is taking it 150
miles away has a contract
how would you mitigate that because
obviously we want to put the food closer
to minimize the carbon footprint how
would this into would this interfere
with the contracts How would how would
we look at that well
um according to
my other source which was Hannaford
according to them they look at the food
waste reduction hierarchy and what they
want to do first of all is get the food
to the hungry and so they initially you
know work with food banks and Farmers to
get that number down and after that then
they they
um
they work with somebody who can take it
and and compost it or digest it I I also
just want to point out here that you
know if there's enough food waste to
support a digester more composting
facilities at farms that sort of thing
that's a business generator and that
would bring the infrastructure in closer
which would reduce your haulage costs
and the carbon footprint and reduce
let's face it what's going into our
landfills so that we can preserve our
capacity representative Bixby yes I was
going to ask if this would create a
business opportunity for New Hampshire
business New Hampshire rights who wanted
to start businesses but I believe the
representative just answered that thank
you which is the point of my next bill
yeah but anyway any other questions from
the committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
very thorough testimony and introduction
of the bill we really appreciate it okay
I'd like any other additional questions
I'd be happy to answer them thank you
thank you I'd like to call Michael Nork
from nhdes
but put your mic on thank you good
morning Madam chairman members of the
committee my name uh for the record is
Michael Nork I'm with the solid waste
management Bureau at New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
um thank you for the opportunity to
testify on HB 300
um
the purpose of this bill as we see it is
to discourage disposal of food waste
and encourage its diversion to more
preferable management through feeding
the hungry feeding animals
composting anaerobic digestion and
things of that nature so that's not
going into a landfill or an incinerator
although we are not taking a position on
this bill we do support the intent of
the bill
and we do wish to provide the committee
with some information and express two
concerns that we have with the bill as
currently written
um first of all I think it's important
to note that this kind of policy has
been implemented in other New England or
actually other Northeastern states
including New York
Massachusetts Connecticut Rhode Island
and Vermont
um so this this legislation tracks
fairly closely with how those bills
started some of those bills started
which with with similar thresholds and
have ratcheted them down over time but
the fact of the matter is that this kind
of legislation has been implemented in
other states it has been shown to
encourage development of infrastructure
for management of food waste alternative
management other than landfilling or
incineration there's been a flurry of
investment in other states for
building composting infrastructure
anaerobic digestion infrastructure and
also increasing networks for Food
donation
um and for New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services as was mentioned
by representative evil we have recently
issued a solid waste management plan
food waste diversion is an identified
priority in that plan
and it's an important strategy for
decreasing the amount of waste that we
send to landfills according to the EPA
um they have estimates that up to 24 of
MSW which is Municipal Solid Waste
that's the basically although it's
called Municipal Solid Waste it's
actually waste that's generated by the
community at large so it could be
residents and businesses so the estimate
from the EPA is that 20 up to 24 of the
MSW stream Nationwide is food waste and
while MSW is not the only thing that
ends up in a landfill it is the largest
component of the disposal stream so
making a dent in food waste can make a
dent in the amount of waste that we send
um we don't have exact data and how much
food waste was disposed of in New
Hampshire but we did use the epa's
estimate of 24 we applied it to uh the
total amount of MSW that Granite Staters
sent to disposal in 2021 so we estimate
that there could be up to 180 000 tons
of food wastes going to landfills at
least based on 2021 data so that's a
significant amount and if we can make a
dent in that we can it's it's an
important strategy to consider because
the
um legislature in the past couple years
as representative Ebel noted has updated
the disposal goal for the state the
disposal reduction goal which is an RSA
149 M2
to reduce disposal of MSW and c and d by
25 by the year 2030 and 45 percent by
the year 2050. so again MSW is one of
the components of that goal and food
so
you know as I mentioned this kind of
policy has been implemented in other
states it has shown uh promise in terms
of being able to incentivize development
of new infrastructure to manage food
waste that's one of the things that
we've identified as a need in New
Hampshire we don't currently have robust
composting infrastructure or anaerobic
digestion or we do have food networks
food you know recovery networks but this
kind of policy has shown in other states
to really incentivize development of
those kinds of systems
um and so we think that this could have
similar impacts for New Hampshire
however the department does have two
concerns with the bill as currently
written number one
um the bill uh would impose new
responsibilities on DES in terms of
regulating
the food
service industry uh you know other kinds
of large food waste generators as
representative people mentioned like
grocery stores hospitals
correctional facilities
food manufacturers and food processors
these are these are entities that
currently we don't regulate so this
would be an expansion of our
responsibilities and so when considering
this we estimate that we would probably
need at least one full full-time
equivalent employee to be able to
adequately implement this kind of
disposal ban however the bill doesn't
provide for that and and I do recognize
that this this committee is maybe not as
focused on the fiscal side of things and
this will probably go to the fiscal
committee but we did want to just raise
that as a consideration the second
concern we have is the 50 mile radius
um and we do note that that is more uh
more stringent than the kind of radius
that's implemented in similar bands in
other states
um is typically they they have a 20 mile
radius
um and as representative evil noted
Massachusetts is the only one that
doesn't have any stipulation for
distance so basically any generator in
the state of Massachusetts is required
to divert food waste
Vermont initially had a 20 mile radius
they initially started this in 2014. and
they slowly stepped it down over time
until 2021 when any generator in the
state is required to divert their food
waste so they they did start with a
20-mile radius but they slowly stepped
it down over time I'm just mentioning
that as as things that the committee
might consider in terms of implementing
policy for New Hampshire
um so I guess that's really that that
sums up the the comments that the
department had but if there are any
questions that the committee might have
for the Department I'm happy to to field
those
questions from the committee
representative Creighton
all right thank you madam chair thank
you for your testimony uh just a quick
question in the physical note in the
back here it has 97 000 for a a uh one
one employee is that in line with what
your thoughts are on that if this goes
forward
yeah thank you representative Creighton
that that fiscal note was based on
information that we provided to LBA um
so that is that is the estimate that we
made cool
okay
may I uh just just to clarify one point
on on I think it was representative
smart had uh comment about date labels
um I'm sorry if I'm incorrected and who
yeah
I just wanted to clarify that with
regard to the date labels my
understanding is that
well while New Hampshire Department of
Health and Human Services may have food
safety regulations that apply in certain
contexts they are not I don't believe
that they have oversight over date
labels and I think that in general date
labels are largely up to the
manufacturer there's sell by there's
Best Buy those don't always mean that
the food is inedible and there's also
Federal
legislation the bill Emerson Good
Samaritan act which does provide
liability protections for individuals or
businesses that want to donate food in
good faith so I'm not sure exactly the
you know all the ins and outs but I know
that there are certain liability
protections and that
food date labels aren't always the be
all end-all usually a better indicator
is using your nose to see if it smells
bad
but but I understand that some
businesses may have concerns about
um you know whether something isn't
effect edible or not
representative Morse
thank you thank you for taking my
question on um just going off of that a
little bit more would it be possible for
farmers and composters to just enter
into food gathering with a contract so
that they agree you know they're not
going to eat expired food and get sick
and Sue it would be strictly for
composting
uh thank you representative Morse I
think
um
that that is possible and and I'm not a
lawyer and I don't really understand all
the ins and outs of like those kinds of
legal agreements but
um I think in general what would happen
is if food waste was diverted to a farm
it probably
would be the kind of stuff that would be
for composting anyway it wouldn't really
be like you wouldn't want to send stuff
to a farm and then have the farm sorted
out
uh you really want to get food that's
edible to the place where it can be used
as quickly as possible and most Farms or
composters are going to take stuff
that's kind of already mixed with other
you know petressable waste it's not
really going to be in a condition that
is is edible
um
I don't know if that answers your
question but
thank you
representative Bixby
yes thank you for taking my question
um so you said that Vermont initially
started with a 20 uh 20 mile radius and
then ratcheted that down but I wouldn't
it so
in terms of making him you you're saying
that they're made it more stringent so I
would assume that they increased the
mileage until the point where it wasn't
because 50 miles is stricter than 20.
that's a good question I may have
misspoke I think
let me let me back up and just say that
the intent with these kinds of bills is
to have implementation delayed so you
have a year two or three before the food
waste disposal ban goes into effect
so that it allows time for
infrastructure to be developed that's
what happened in Vermont that's what
happened in in Massachusetts they they
basically said we're going to do this
but it's not going to start until such
date
and it gave it gave a signal to the
industry saying okay there's going to be
a demand for my services so I should
start investing and looking for
opportunities to start a business in
such and such state
um
so so it gives that time to allow for
development of infrastructure
and
with Vermont where I may have misspoke
was
they they ratcheted down not the
distance so much as the the threshold so
they started with two tons per week then
one time the the next year
then I forgot maybe been two-thirds of a
ton or half a ton or something like that
so they slowly over time over the course
of like six years
um
ratcheted down the threshold
for total tonnage generated by an entity
um meanwhile all along there was a 20
mile radius until 2021 when they got rid
of that because the presumption was
after that amount of time had passed
there would be enough infrastructure to
support kind of Statewide uh
it's a version of food waste from any
generator regardless of the the
threshold or the the amount that that
facility generates
so in Vermont currently they don't have
a tonnage threshold and they also don't
thank you any other questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony this morning I'd like to call
Reagan investment from nrra to come and
speak
can you hear me now
my name is Reagan Bissonnet and I'm the
executive director of the Northeast
resource recovery Association we are a
recycling non-profit we work with 85
percent of the communities in New
Hampshire to help them manage their own
recycling programs
and
in 2021 we helped communities recycle
enough material that we were able to
return over 3.8 million dollars to New
Hampshire communities to help them
improve their recycling programs from
the sale of their recyclables the
benefit of that recycling actually also
reduction of greenhouse gas emissions
equivalent to removing almost 21 000
cars from the road for an entire year so
communities in New Hampshire are
recycling and having a very positive
impact on the environment here
so the Northeast resource recovery
Association does not take a position on
any proposed legislation but I did want
to share some information just from the
perspective of how this type of
legislation might impact New Hampshire
municipalities
I'll also note that I'm a member of the
solid waste working group along with
representative evil and I also served on
a subcommittee of that group that
focused on Recycling and composting when
we were working to advise the Department
of Environmental Services on the
development of its current Solid Waste
Management plan
so as you already heard food waste is a
very large component of the municipal
household waste that's disposed of in
New Hampshire and across the country so
there's a number of benefits for
communities to reduce that waste one of
the things I'd like to add is that it's
very expensive for communities to
dispose of trash in New Hampshire in the
Northeast we have the highest cost of
disposal for Waste going to landfills or
incinerators compared to the entire rest
of the country and that is in part
because we have the least amount of
available space for building new or
expanding landfills we also have a high
water table relative to many other
places so it leaves less opportunities
for digging new landfills so it really
is quite an expense for communities to
dispose of waste and anything that can
be done to help communities reduce the
amount of waste that they need to throw
away
can it help them save money
so
as I think representative Ebel already
noted the current Solid Waste Management
plan certainly
encourages uh ways to reduce the amount
of food waste that's being disposed of
in New Hampshire
and so certainly a disposal ban like
this was contemplated as the working
group was considering ways in which uh
the legislature might consider
addressing food waste since it is such a
large component of our our waste that
we're disposing
um
you know perhaps more importantly from
the perspective of municipalities
anything that the state can do to
provide more opportunities for towns and
cities to uh dispose of food waste
through composting or anaerobic
digestion certainly has the opportunity
to help communities save money so one
specific example I'll give we actually
hear from many of our members that they
are interested in ways that they could
compost or otherwise divert their food
waste but there are some limited
opportunities here in New Hampshire
there are a few communities that
actually compost their food waste on
site the city of Lebanon does so and
also the town of Hollis and those
programs have been pretty popular with
residents
the city of Lebanon actually found that
through a pilot program they've actually
been composting
food waste from uh Dartmouth Hitchcock
Medical Center and also Dartmouth
College for many years and they began a
pilot program to also divert and compost
food waste from residents and what the
city of Lebanon found from that pilot
project was that they were ultimately
saving about 30 percent
in terms of what it would cost them to
landfill that food waste versus
composting it so there were Financial
savings for the city of Lebanon and the
communities that it serves and
ultimately that pilot project was quite
successful and so they decided to make
that a more permanent project where
residents can bring their food scraps to
their facility for composting and they
have continued to take material from
Dartmouth collagen and Dartmouth
Hitchcock
in addition there are some communities
in New Hampshire that have access to
composting services so for example there
are communities on the Seacoast that
work with Mr Fox compost it's a company
based in Maine and you heard about how
generators can have those large totes
and so for example the town of Lee and
the town of Rye they work with Mr Fox
compost and basically residents can
bring their food scraps separated to the
transfer station put them in those big
totes and then Mr Fox compost can take
those totes and bring them to their
facility in Maine to compost that
material
um
so you know even though we don't take a
position on this bill I just wanted to
to stress that to the extent that
this or other legislation can increase
markets or infrastructure for composting
food scraps or even um you know
anaerobic digestion of food scraps that
ultimately has the potential of really
helping communities in New Hampshire
have greater access to those markets so
that they can save money
um
you know certainly many communities do
encourage their residents to do backyard
composting and that's a great option
um I for example compost my food scraps
in my backyard but just last night I
discovered that the snowplow had
destroyed my compost bin because it's
next to my driveway and so it'd be very
convenient if my community actually
provided Municipal uh you know
composting services and certainly we get
a lot of inquiries from residents as
and that's all I wanted to share happy
to answer any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony I call Clark courson
to come this morning before us and uh I
see
you are from collaborative Solid Waste
strategies
please put on your microphone
thank you
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee
as you can see not much west coast of
um
I am a co-founder and program director
for a non-profit in New Hampshire called
collaborative Solid Waste strategies
our goal is to
serve as a catalyst for new ways looking
outside the box for sustainable Solid
Waste strategy strategization
and one of the great problems that we
have in New Hampshire is that of
regionalization every town thinks that
their system is the best and they're not
going to listen to the neighbor because
they're competing with them for
temperature fees and so forth or the
reverse of that trying to get rid of
their garbage for the cheapest price
possible
I'm not going to speak to the specifics
of the bill but I was a lobbyist in this
state for 41 and a half years they
started in 1971.
and during the course of that I learned
how to read a bill
my
I have no objections to the bill is
written
but I second the comments made by
Michael Nook of Des
in terms of distance
which is in in and in terms of how far
behind our state of New Hampshire has
fallen compared to other states he
mentioned the fact that there has been a
and we're just addressing this now why
do you know that
about 50 percent
of the solid waste that goes to the
turnkey T4 operation of Rochester New
Hampshire comes from Massachusetts every
day
a lot of people aren't aware of that
a lot of people aren't aware of the fact
that Vermont has had a solid waste study
plan since 2000 1994 or 1997 whatever it
is
and the last time a governor in this
state paid attention to this issue was
Gene Shaheen in 2003.
the the woman sitting behind me Karen
Ebel a representative from New London
New Hampshire has been the catalyst
for the general court in my opinion
but tackling this huge problem and it
really is the more you get into it the
more you realize it's a science because
whether it's food
nanograms of plastic in our bloodstreams
what's going into the landfills who's
transporting it the interstate
transportation
Commission
the recovery and resource conservation
Act of 1976 which was
which was initiated by EPA
the more you get into this the more you
realize that this just isn't House Bill
300 is just not a bill it is a it is a
process it's not an event
and it has come about because of
Representative evil principally
I don't know whether she's capable of
blushing or not
but anyway
so I I don't want to take up the
committee sign but I want to tell you
that uh
collaborative Solid Waste strategies is
going to work with this legislature to
try to come up with looking outside the
box
not concentrating on landfills and
incineration but how can we contribute
that much less to the process as it
currently exists
so you guys sit on a critically
important standing committee in This
House of Representatives
and I take my hat off to you
that concludes my testimony I'll take
any questions thank you Mr Colson any
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much for
coming and speaking with us this morning
thank you a call Representative Megan
Murray to the uh
table there
good morning representative Murray
says two minutes
I'll do my best I promise
um good morning Madam chair
um
thank you honorable colleagues Health
environment and agriculture I come
before you as a mom and a legislator for
whom the last few days have been a
little bit challenging without power so
I have my testimony handwritten for you
so I apologize for that
um
that said I uh represent the towns of
Amherst and Milford that's Hillsboro
District 37. I'm here in support of HB
300 as a co-sponsor in an effort to
address what is one of the most uh
copious items in our waste streams and
that is food waste
it's heavy
it has purpose outside of our landfills
and it contributes to a large portion of
methane gas production once it ends up
in our landfills as the clerk to House
Bill 617 which was the study committee
that representative Ebel mentioned into
and the chair of the house uh Ena
subcommittee On Solid Waste I fully
support the desire to stop sending large
quantities of food to landfills our
preferences on food uh waste is to First
limit how much spoilage we actually do
have overage
um or waste in the first place but then
our responsibility is to move closer to
getting uh the food to those who need it
feeding animals
and then after all of those efforts are
exhausted
um then the usable food has gone to
those who benefit most and consider what
we do with that food waste and spoilage
or overage it might surprise you that
the food waste that food waste is so
heavy and dense
and we know it's costly to transport
ultimately to a would-be resting ground
uh whereby uh composting it and also
working towards our race reduction goals
is preferable
we can collectively support composting
which AIDS in the contribute uh
contribution of um reinfusing our soils
with nutrient nutrients
um as well as the composting process
there also has other methods too like
anaerobic digestion that help in dealing
with our food waste after
we've done all of the other food
hierarchy methods
well one ton of waste in uh food weight
may not seem like a lot we have heard in
countless testimonies before the house
CNA committees
that food grown and produced in the
United States
often does go to waste I know you've
heard some other statistics but roughly
on an annual basis 218 billion with a B
billion dollars in food waste
occurs each year in the United States
and of food grown
in the United States 30 percent of what
is grown and produced as a food
commodity ends up as waste before us
sending our food uh to a landfill
is our least preferred method of
disposal of the six options that we do
have and the time is right to do what we
can to keep our food hierarchy and
Recovery moving in the direction that we
know the U.S EPA prefers
and I've I know that you've heard from
Des in regards to that matter and I I do
urge the passage of HB 300 if I can also
speak to some of the other efforts that
had been mentioned by representative
smart I do know when you mentioned the
donation of food I had worked very
diligently on a an alternative method to
um getting food to those who are hungry
and that was signed into law and that
was HB 500 it did
um work with what are called hassip food
safety protocols which I did work with
DHHS on and so long as the food had
comported with food safety regulations
prior to it being served it was able to
be then repackaged and repurposed into
usable portions that would go to
communities we're now seeing those
efforts underway in communities like
Great Bay Community College and others
so um those efforts are there I am a
small
I own chickens as well and so I do as
much as I can to get that food first you
know to my family or donate it and then
after that it goes to my hands and after
that then there's there's composting so
I I appreciate that and I'm happy to
take any questions that the committee
may have thank you representative Murray
any questions from the committee
thank you
I'd like to call Carol Foss from New
Hampshire Audubon to come and speak this
morning and uh you've asked for two
foreign good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee
um I will be brief my name is Carol Foss
I am representing New Hampshire Audubon
where I am Senior advisor for Science
and policy
um we strongly support House Bill 300
um
because it reduces greenhouse gases
conserve space in landfills
supports the goals of New Hampshire's
Solid Waste Management plan and supports
the goals of
the Environmental Protection Agency and
the Department of Agriculture who are
trying to
reduce Weight Food waste going to
landfills
um
as well Nationwide as you've heard it
creates jobs reduces food insecurity and
saves money for communities
I'd also like to quickly address the
questions about food date labels
um they are very confusing some
companies
have a sell-by date some have a use by
date some just have a date and you don't
know what it means
um
some of the dates are addressing quality
and some are addressing safety and one
of our neighboring states I can't
remember which one I think it might be
Massachusetts
has a bill before their current
legislature to standardize date labels
so that it's clear to the consumer
whether it's a quality issue or a safety
issue and that may be something we'll
see how it goes with our neighbors but
that may be something that we want to
consider as well
thank you thank you for your testimony
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much for
coming this morning
and I'd like to call Heidi tremario I
believe
from the conservation law Foundation
good morning
good morning thank you it's Heidi
tremarco I'm sorry I apologize for my uh
handwriting on the Forum that is my
error and you've also requested two
minutes yes I will keep it very short I
do we did submit our comments over email
but I have copies here if the committee
would you like them you pass it around
foreign
so thank you chair and members of the
committee to keep it very brief because
of the plea the most of the points have
already been made clf also strongly
supports this bill for the reasons that
you've heard that it will support
diversion
um as you've heard and I have a
reference in our comments that EPA does
estimate that up to 24 of the waste in
our landfills is food waste so this is a
great great chunk of waste that you
could tackle and reach and help reach
our diversion goals which as you heard
is to get to 25 diversion by 2030.
um and uh these goals were reinforced in
the state's Solid Waste Management plan
which was just updated this fall and
this diversion would support those goals
specifically goals one three and four in
that plan
also in helping with food insecurity it
would assist in the goal seven which is
to address environmental justice
and so we strongly support the bill I'm
happy to take questions I also just
wanted to note on a personal note I
compost my food at the Lebanon
composting facility and I'm not 11 on
Resident but we drive our food waste
there and it's extremely convenient and
I could answer questions about how that
works for us thank you for your
thank you for joining us this morning
thank you
I'd like to call Bonnie Christie up to
testify this morning and um please if
you have something new to contribute
please do so if you have something that
has already been said we have heard that
I have some a slightly different
perspective to contribute and I think I
misspelled your name on the testimony
sorry
no worries um Bonnie Christie I live in
Hopkinton and I'm the chair of our waste
reduction committee
um thank you for taking my statement I
support this bill because it will help
to implement several of the goals of the
New Hampshire Solid Waste Management
plan which we've heard quite a bit about
this morning goal one of that plan is
Source reduction you don't create waste
you don't have to manage it you don't
have to pay people to manage it you
don't have to pay tipping fees at the
landfill
um in Hopkinton this is a big expense
for us we have seen a 20 increase in our
waste over the last decade and our
population has only grown by five
percent our tipping fees are going up
and up and up every year
and we don't expect that to go down so
this is a concern for us how can we
reduce our waste costs
so goal number one of the statement
Waste Management plan reinforces the
original hierarchy in our waste
reduction methods of putting Source
reduction at the top and getting away
from the landfilling and incineration
goal two is about toxicity and then this
brings us to goal three of the plan
which HB 300 addresses
even with the best efforts we'll always
have some waste that we produce and we
try once we do Source reduction we try
to divert the waste that we can't avoid
the two methods of that are generally
Recycling and composting
um
I I'll also note people have mentioned
methane as a problem we're very
concerned about that in Hopkinton
because we know that methane is a far
more potent greenhouse gas than CO2 and
landfills are the third largest source
in our country of of methane after oil
and gas systems and livestock raising
so the two ways that we have worked in
most municipalities work to to divert
their waste as I said Recycling and
composting recycling has done really
well in our town we have
generated in in about a decade 400 and
over 438 thousand dollars in Revenue
we've avoided over four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in tipping fees
and we've kept 6 700 tons of waste out
of landfills and incinerators
so this if you calculate the 24 percent
of
Municipal solid waste that you've heard
EPA is that's what they estimate for us
that would be a savings of sixty nine
thousand seven hundred and fifty dollars
if we were to divert our food waste
so um you've also heard that there are
pilot programs that are springing up
around New Hampshire Lebanon and our
neighbor New London
in 2020 the Hopkinton waste reduction
committee recruited a test group of
residents to separate out their food
scraps from their household waste waste
and they had an average diversion rate
of 45 percent
which we were very surprised and pleased
with
in 2022 we began a collaborative program
with worksong Farm which is one of our
local csas and the composting
Association of Vermont it's called turn
your slops into crops
and the way it works is the CSA members
bring their food scraps when they pick
up their share every week they drop them
off they go home with a new clean bucket
and start all over again and the purpose
of this program is to enrich the soil at
worksong farm so Dan kilrain who owns it
is loving this program it's been so
successful he has opened it up to the
General Public
which is great
people are always amazed at how much
weight they they find food scraps
produce in their household waste
so we think that composting and I know
this is that this bill addresses more of
a vision of commercial composting but we
think if that can get started and
trickle down to a local level it can be
a huge help to municipalities we know
Hopkinton would welcome it
um
and we also know that if we could have
regionalized composting that would
capitalize on efficiencies and produce
more effective results and that also
addresses goal number five of the state
Solid Waste Management plan which is to
create new markets for for Waste
diversion waste related so that's pretty
much it I'm happy to answer any
questions I did submit my testimony
online and I have a couple of hard
copies
thank you would you send a hard copy up
to our clerk here that would be very
helpful appreciate it thank you for your
testimony any questions for Ms Christie
seeing none thank you I have no more
pink cards does anybody else wish to say
anything about this
seeing none I will go ahead and close
the hearing on this bill HB 300 thank
okay let me give our clerk a moment to
uh
oh I'm sorry I neglected to say
thank you
we have
um
more people that uh wrote in that they
were for this legislation and online we
had
um
61 support and two in opposition
it's the blue sheet so thank you are you
all set for
yeah
with that I'd like to
um
open up the hearing for HB 462
make an appropriation to the solid waste
management fund and targeting food waste
reduction and diversion
and I would like to invite
representative evil up again to give us
her testimony on this important
legislation
thank you very much Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Karen Ebel I represent
Merrimack District 7 which is New London
and Newbury excuse me I'm here to
introduce HB 462 which is um an
amendment
foreign
to the solid waste management fund which
was created by the legislature uh last
year
um
I think you've heard an awful lot about
composting at this point so I uh I won't
go through all of the benefits of doing
more composting as part of this hearing
I I just wanted to point out that this
is a quite a simple in my opinion
straightforward bill it's here before
this committee for policy reasons
and that is that we're suggesting that
we make a slight a couple of tweaks to
the to the terms of the solid waste
management fund
um in particular now that you've perhaps
heard all you ever want to hear about
the benefits of composting
um the the solid waste
um
the solid waste working group have had
discussed this in great detail and
because we're really
interested in promoting the concept of
composting in the state of New Hampshire
for all the reasons that were described
in the previous hearing we thought that
the language in the solid waste managed
fund statute should be tweaked slightly
and in the bill it's line 12 just to say
that assuming we get the appropriation
which the finance committee will be
considering 50 percent should be given
to prioritize projects associated with
the reduction in diversion of food food
waste and organic waste for until June
30th 2027.
so that's one of the primary reasons the
uh that the bill is here the other
um reason is just to expand the uh
manners in which money can flow into the
fund through the whole flurry of
activity last year with um through the
amendment process what what was left
here was that the management fund could
take money from the Environmental
Protection Agency but there was nothing
else noted and I want to thank Des for
their technical assistance in
identifying this issue because obviously
if we want to be able to get gifts
donations legislative appropriations of
any of that anything of that nature
we've got to make provision for it in
the bill so that's what the earlier uh
part of it is
um
as was noted by Reagan B sinat when she
was talking about the benefits to
municipalities we want to help develop
more of an infrastructure in our state
we and one of the things that will help
motivate this is if we use some of the
Appropriations that I hope we receive
through the budget process
using part of the proceeds from the fund
to help promote infrastructure I know
that you could also be using these
monies for for Education
Outreach there's any number of uses and
I also want to note that the way this
fund was created is that municipalities
and businesses can afford themselves of
the matching grant program which would
also help businesses especially smaller
ones move forward to try to help develop
infrastructure not just for com posting
although we certainly have that as a a
recommendation for the first couple of
years of the fund but also for other uh
recycling Source reduction and diversion
opportunities
so
the only other thing really that I want
to add here is that one of the looming
issues that I had talked about before
with regard to Solid Waste Management in
our state
also is reflected in the solid waste
management plan and I've noted that in
my testimony that establishing a
reliable source of funding for solid
waste management is incredibly important
in our state and that one of the ways of
achieving this is the solid waste
management fund
and
um I'm hoping that assuming you as the
policy committee agree with the changes
to the statute within the fund we can
promptly get it over to the finance
committee where
um it can be discussed as part of the
budget process
so I thank you very much and if you have
any questions I'd be happy to answer
them thank you representative evil any
questions from the committee
representative Bixby thank you for
taking my question so uh there was some
testimony online that suggested that the
phrasing of the sourcing of the fund
sourcing might be a little bit ambiguous
and uh so uh just to clarify so it says
any Source including gifts donations of
money grants legislative approach
Appropriations and any other matching
fund and incentives from the United
States Environmental Protection Agency
or other agencies that are targeted for
making grants within with this with this
section uh and is the
it sounds like the the
um Environmental Protection Agency
incentives from the Environmental
Protections Agency part might be
governing all of the parts before that
and uh I was wondering if you would be
willing to have an amendment that would
uh clarify that so that the
Environmental Protection Agency would
count as just one rather than uh the
complete funding I would be more than
happy to put any amendment in that
allows this fund to get money from
virtually everywhere including Manna
From Heaven so if you if you want to
work on that
um I mean I'd be happy to work with you
I I did want to say uh one thing about
the Environmental Protection Agency the
funding that folks were really excited
about coming through the infrastructure
act for recycling activities at the rate
of I think about 55 million dollars a
year the guidelines had not been issued
at the time this bill at the time that
the fund was created
and I think a lot of us were hopeful
that the money from that from the EPA
could go into this fund
although the guidelines can change over
time the initial guidelines that came
down from EPA do not permit states to
apply for the funding and then use the
funding as a sub-grant program and and
director wimsat could answer more
questions on this so at this point
unless the guidelines change that EPA
recycling money is not uh available for
sadly thank you any other questions from
the committee
seeing none
I'd like to thank you for your
introduction of this bill okay thank you
and I'll Now call up Mike wimsat
good morning Madam chair
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Mike Wimsatt my
service director of the waste management
division for the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
appreciate the opportunity to come
before you to testify on House Bill 462
this morning
so
I know you've heard a lot about Organics
and you've heard a little bit about the
solid waste plan and the solid waste
management fund this morning so I'll
just sort of summarize the Department's
testimony as follows the fund was
established as uh representative evil
mentioned back you know in the last
session of the legislature in order to
provide matching grants to improve uh
for projects that would improve waste
reduction and waste diversion to really
help us improve Recycling and and to
achieve our waste reduction goals and uh
last fall we issued a update to our
Solid Waste Management plan that has a
host of goals and strategies and actions
to to try to in large part to try to
achieve that disposal reduction goal and
I think it's really clear to us that
this this fund is going to need to play
a significant role in achieving those
goals
um so you've heard an awful lot about
um
uh food waste and organic waste and
composting this morning so I won't
review that my let my litter of
testimony does talk about that a little
bit we we absolutely feel that you know
because as you've learned this morning
if you didn't already know it food waste
and Organics waste constitutes a really
significant portion of the MSW the
municipal solid waste that gets disposed
of here in our state working on that and
making progress on on diverting and
reducing that waste is a really
important activity so we completely
support this uh effort to uh
um you know put some funding into the uh
the solid waste management fund and to
Target you know at least 50 percent of
those funds toward food and organic
waste reduction we don't take it we're
not taking a position with respect to
where the money ought to come from
that's we leave that to the legislature
in the governor's office to sort that
out but for our part it is true that the
fund was created last year and does not
have any funding in it so it's hard for
us to be effective with it if we don't
have any uh any funds to work with and
so with that I'll just open up to any
questions be glad to entertain questions
thank you for your testimony any any
questions from the committee I have a
question
so part of this two million dollar
appropriation
would go to paying that full-time FTE of
to to oversee composting or or
well a recycling program sure well it
would actually an important to
understand Des has a lot of experience
giving out money right because we we
operate two State revolving funds we've
been administering millions of dollars
in arpa funds and one thing we've
learned is that it takes a little bit of
personnel and money to to get give money
out and we've got a lot of folks looking
over our shoulder about how we do that
about how we go about that and it's
important that we do it carefully and
and in compliance with the law and in
compliance with any provisions in the
case of like the arpa funds we have
specific Federal requirements we need to
comply with so yeah it's certainly true
we do need to to have a position that
could oversee that it would not be
specifically for food and organic waste
we would see it as a position that would
oversee among other things
advertising uh competition for that
grant funding making those grants and
then administering those grants after
they've been awarded so that that and as
we as we read it we understand that you
know a portion of those funds would be
available to to make sure that we did
um
I had another question I now I'm drawing
a blank so thank you for your testimony
I guess I representative Bixby yeah I'd
just like to follow up on uh
representative Aaron's question because
I'm not sure you quite got the exact
gist of it in the previous in the
testimony on SB on the HB 300 uh there's
a fiscal note on that which is basically
the ninety seven thousand dollars for
one person who would be necessary in
order to uh oversee the uh the programs
under s HB 300 and the ques I think
represent representative Aaron's
question was would that position be able
to come out of the appropriation in HB
462.
uh that's that's not clear to me I I I'm
not sure that's the case
I apologize if I didn't address your
question properly follow up sure so uh
it may in fact be necessary for us to
figure out a way to uh see that there
would be an appropriation attached to uh
HB 300 to cover the position that it
would require in order to oversee it
I believe that may be true I mean I'm
not commenting on whether the Bills
should be amended or not but I but again
to answer the question very directly I
don't think that funding appropriated to
the solid waste management fund would be
available to create a position to
administer other programs right and and
I I think the point of uh of this
question is we want to make sure you
have the
um resources to do both of these bills
right and if we need to do something
additional to one of them in order to
make sure that happens we want to be
able to do it understood thank you
okay thank you representative Bixby and
thank you for clarifying my question
um actually I do remember what I wanted
to ask you was
um with the
administration of this two million
dollar fund
uh do you see the need to put together
any uh further rules for managing this
fund or do you have those in place based
on what was passed last year because I
don't know we do not currently have
rules but we generally if we are going
to administer an ongoing grant program
using State funds we would develop rules
to to govern how those how those funds
are administered
and as a follow-up to that do you have
an idea of time frame of when those
rules would be established
uh typically we try to
a lot for rule making is around about
six months from the start of the
rulemaking process I think there would
be a few months in advance of that
developing those we try to keep rules
related to making grants as simple as
possible one advantage we have is that
we do administer a number of Grant
programs either using federal or state
funds so we kind of have a template for
how we can do that so I I would
anticipate that you know in six to nine
months we could probably develop rules
for something like that thank you very
much
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you very much for your testimony
this morning
and I'd like to call Representative
Murray to testify
thank you madam chair once again for the
record my name is Megan Murray I
represent the towns of Amherst and
Milford
and under what I would consider the
mentorship of Representative Ebel and
many others right here in house
environment and agriculture I have set
out to understand the context nature of
solid waste here in New Hampshire
in one of the many
opportunities that I have had to hear
from New Hampshire Des are communities
in municipalities one thing I hear
clearly
our
um how anemic the funds are for our
Solid Waste division of Des and frankly
the monies and resources for Waste
diversion and recycling truly are
it's a little known fact that we do not
necessarily have dedicated funds to
always
put forth the uh things that we would
like to do around waste disposal goals
to stand up programs or grants or assist
our local communities with programs to
help address the goal of food waste
reduction in our waste streams year over
year since I've begun this work here in
this committee municipalities have Long
Pine for help around tipping fees
and the sheer volume of what goes into
our landfills leaving municipality waste
budgets strained all while knowing that
trash is something every single one of
us produces and contends with
DS's Solid Waste division has stated the
true need for additional staff and
resources to keep going with the at
times overdue tasks the necessary work
of assessing assisting communities with
Recycling and waste diversion goals and
the efforts are related to them
this bill is strongly bipartisan and
adheres to our hierarchy goals and
offers help to communities towns and the
Department of Environmental Services
in much needed fiscal Appropriations to
the solid waste management fund so that
the work we need to do with and by our
communities can be done
I urge the support of HB 462 FNA so that
New Hampshire can be stronger in our
work to address the recommendations out
of the solid waste working group and to
bring supports to the towns and the
Departments
that deal with our Solid Waste
and uh with regarding to our Solid Waste
Disposal goals also thank you
thank you representative Murray any
questions
seeing none
I would like to again call Reagan
please put your uh microphone on thank
you
so I won't I won't repeat what I already
shared about the importance of food
waste diversion and why that would be
helpful for communities to both save
money and make improvements in the
environment in New Hampshire what I
would like to share is that there is a
real need for communities in New
Hampshire to receive more technical
assistance and ideally grant funding to
support increasing their waste diversion
so the Northeast resource recovery
Association as I said we work with the
vast majority of communities in New
Hampshire and we get many many endless
requests for resources that are
available to them to help them
financially to increase their recycling
improve their recycling reduce the food
waste that they're disposing and while
our organization can provide a lot of
technical assistance through our staff
they're really very limited grant
opportunities available to these
communities so we we
routinely get requests for hey this is
something we want to do in our community
just recently a community reached out
and said we'd like to
you know start a composting program we
would like to share that information
with our residents we'd like to improve
um how our residents are recycling
Plastics and they asked what Grant is
out there that can fund all of these
needs and I was able to share with them
that there are a handful of grants
available but that I wasn't aware of any
that would specifically help them with
that type of education and Outreach to
their residents so for example there are
a handful of federal grants that are
available for communities
federal grants are very difficult to
typically apply for and receive funding
for an administer
the an organization called New Hampshire
the beautiful does provide recycling
equipment grants for communities here in
New Hampshire up to a certain amount of
money and that is certainly helpful but
again anything that the state can do to
support funds being available to support
communities more with increasing their
waste diversion with certainly be
valuable
thank you thank you
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you again for your
testimony
and I would like to call Elizabeth
Miller
to our
welcome to environment and agriculture
it's mellor m-e-l-l-e-r
that's correct thank you
my name is Elizabeth Miller I am from
New London New Hampshire I'm a member of
the wage reduction committee and I have
a written testimony
I'm a member of New Ham New London's
waste reduction committee and I am very
interested in this bill which seeks to
amend the use of the
solid waste management to prioritize
food waste diversion in our state Our
Town funded a pilot program for food
scrap diversion via the revolving
recycling fund we had 20 households
participate and after three months they
have diverted 1.5 tons of food scraps
from the waste stream
as we seek to educate our community
residents and businesses about the state
of our landfills and the value of food
scrap diversion we have learned that
even these Endeavors have a cost
attached
thus we are now scrambling to find grant
money to help us educate the public as
well
according to our 2021 annual Town report
Our Town hauled 2300 tons to mount
Carberry if we are to reduce this amount
by 25 percent then by 2030 we need to
divert
575 tons
for small towns like ours this will take
a massive amount of effort and resources
to accomplish based on our tiny pilot
program
our waste reduction committee was
fortunate to have the supportive
Department of Public worth director who
offered to get the pilot program off the
ground using his own revolving fund
but as you know the markets in recycling
are frivolous and many municipalities
cannot count on sufficient resources to
fund town-wide Endeavors even on a small
scale
incentivizing economy of scale and
regionalization of food scrap diversion
is best accomplished at the state level
this amendment if funded would help
municipalities to meet the Statewide
goals in food scrap diversion alone or
in conjunction with neighboring towns
now we're very proud of our uh of our
pilot program which are we are now
moving into phase two if it's approved
by our town meeting
uh if there's any questions
I'll be him thank you any questions from
the committee
representative thank you madam chair
um could you just pass your written
next I would like to call Paul carpamil
I'm sorry I
did I sorry
can you hear me okay yeah well good
morning all good morning to you good
morning and uh apologize I'm kind of new
to this process so I prepared like a
whole like waste in nationally wasting
New Hampshire so I'll jump right in
um one of the reasons I'm here I'm based
out of Amherst New Hampshire I was
invited by my State Rep
um and I actually began a program uh
this past year and I'll tell you a
little bit about the history but really
what I'm here to talk about is how we
can start these Regional programs
um and I'll get more into details and
then and scale it so I started with
waste version back in 2021 just last
year with grow Nashua they're small
non-profit out of Nashua and they had
their their own food waste diversion
program we picked up food waste at
residential areas and I last summer was
able to obtain a grant from the
worldwide nature fund they're an NGO
that you may have heard of and they
actually have a food waste tracker
program food waste Warrior program
so I got the funding and I was able to
allocate it to a couple of Hollis
elementary schools and I got the
necessary funding for setting up the
whole food waste program in their
schools and I got things like bins
refrigerators for sure for sharing
weight scales I actually partnered with
CET Center for ecological technology out
of on Northampton and they kind of
provide the know-how and so they
actually came in to the school and kind
of helped operationalize what we were
doing
thankfully I had a really good
Champion by the name of Tara happy she's
a third grade environmental teacher she
one environmental teacher of the year
last year and so she she got this and
she went ahead and took took what I gave
her and set up this great program and I
actually sent you guys a
a a a a a deck but a link to her food
tracker and she's been able to track
food milk and various components write
down right down to the to the numbers
and from that she's been able to kind of
give feedback to the lunch food service
Personnel to how to tweak tweak things
so that is going extremely well at both
hes and as well as Hughes which is uh
I also got a contract in place with
Vanguard Renewables I originally started
with agricycle but I went to Vanguard
because they're much closer more
reasonable
um and we're actually using their
digester and Haverhill Mass
um and what I really like about it is
they actually take the credits the net
measuring credits after they yeah you
know so as you may know a digesters when
you take food waste mix it with
commodore
turns into biogas which generates
electricity and goes on to the onto the
grid and so the net metering credits are
actually given to the Haverhill School
District now granted for going to our
school district but nonetheless it's a
great story
in addition I've been able to set up
Global classrooms I actually do a lot of
work with folks in heltonborg Sweden and
I'll talk a little bit more about them
helzenborg is a Pioneer in food waste
they're one of the top uh five European
green cities
um and I'll talk about them in a second
so actually have conducted a couple of
classrooms with sixth graders about how
food waste is handled in in various in
our country in their country things do
about it
um I was also able to get Dan Velo of
our Shea rep in in Amherst New Hampshire
connected with the agricycle and he was
able to get a six-month
pilot going at the Amherst transfer
station which we're starting February
2nd
so given all this has gone on what we're
starting to to do to do is we're going
to look into create a regional project
through the srld Souhegan Regional
Landfill District this is Amherst
Brookline Hollis Mount Vernon about 28
000 residents about 3 000 students
and 10 schools and the great thing about
the srlds can be funded by both private
and public sourcing
um so this is a real great opportunity
to bring together local government
schools residents and businesses to to
really serve as a model not only for our
Hillsborough County and for the rest of
the state
and so the great part is I've kind of
got a really good handle on what needs
to be done in the schools for example I
provide stipends for some of the
teachers I would like to see us provide
stipends for Food Service Personnel so
they can create more sustainable meals
you know they look at the food tracker
and they can say okay well we threw away
you know chicken burgers
quite a bit so let's let's you know
tweak that let's bring in something else
let's bring in more local food
um and so the great part is because my
relationship with helzenborg I've got
some extremely good examples so these
guys just give you an example in five
years they partnered with 37 schools now
this is the city palsan board and they
got the food numbers down from 40
percent down to 5.9 percent across 37
schools
and you look at Sweden and if you look
at the latitude latitude wise they're up
north of Quebec so if they can do it we
can do it now granted I know we're not
so waiting but they've clearly shown us
um a ways in which you do this to do
this so going forward I feel like by
setting up a a Model A Regional model it
achieves a bunch of different things one
achieves economies of scale
so we can buy food diversion
infrastructure in bulk
we can secure contracts with likes of
Vanguard more efficiently and Vanguard
would appreciate that by having cows
next to each other so they can Surface
the area
local composting uh Hollis already has
composting in place they've been doing
food version for two years under the
direction of Joan their DP Duffy
director
and as I mentioned we can set up a
central relationship with the Township
board so in conclusion in making it a
transition to more sustainable outcomes
if you think about what we're trying to
do in the state for
you know going to Electric
construction all sorts of things food
waste is really a low-hanging fruit it
exists everywhere and we have the
opportunity to create regions in New
Hampshire sponsored by the state to have
local municipalities businesses and
schools play a pivotal part in driving
food version by funding food waste
production and recovery programs in the
community these groups can drive
economies of scale and educate the
public and private about food waste
doing this will help create a supportive
environment to encourage others to
contribute and entice those
yet involved to participate so thank you
thank you for your testimony any any
questions any questions from the
committee
yes representative Bixby so um it sounds
like uh your organization is doing a lot
of great stuff uh can you draw a very
clear connection between what you're
doing and how this bill will help it
yes absolutely and so the idea would be
let's be a prototype for for you guys
and so you can then roll this out and
think of the Lakes Region think of the
North country you know you can't what
I've learned is you can't have like side
load environments you have to bring
together
four or five six towns
get that economies of scale and just
drive down the cost and basically what
you're looking at is is the reason why
we've gotten so much attention is
because the cost to haul away food waste
is starting to go down and so in the in
the in the town of Emerson Hollis it
costs ninety dollars now it went from
Seventeen to ninety to Holloway uh Hall
a one ton of food of General waste away
it costs the sau's 140 dollars to haul
away their waste and so I got a contract
for it's you know it's 275 a month
for all the food waste and so that's
certainly a kind of a green premium
we're over and above but eventually you
know you start getting these economies
of scan you start driving that cost down
and pretty soon you're going to have
principles
coming to you and saying why am I
spending x amount of money generally so
why just give it to you guys and you
guys can do this food diversion project
because it's actually almost cheaper and
socially environmentally so much better
and it's teaching the kids great lessons
that is how so one of the questions I
that I'm still kind of left with is well
and if you're doing so well why do you
need help from the state
oh I mean I have oh why am I help them
say no why do you if if your program is
doing so well right why does the state
need to do anything to help
oh well we need to get funding we need
to get funding I mean I have to go out
and write a grant and so if we get
reasonable funding I mean I had a mini
Grant from WWF it wasn't for a lot of
money it was like ten thousand we need
probably in the order of anywhere from
I'm going to extrapolate here but for
the whole area
towns schools
about seven thousand something like that
right okay so it sounds like a follow-up
so it sounds like if you had funding
from the state then you could expand
this absolutely for a relatively low
investment uh on the state's part
yes so so the idea would be get this
going and so if if if if this bill
passes you've now got a prototype that
you can leverage absolutely and that's
the whole goal yeah drive down the
economy's efficiency of scale and just
make this a very teachable model and
that's really what it is
yep
thank you and and as a follow-up to
representative bixby's question I would
ask too so say you applied for a seven
thousand dollar Grant from
Des that would have this program sure
what would you do with that money
well that money would go towards of
course buying the the the bins the
weight scales
um securing the the contract from the
food Haller you know Vanguard
stipends for the teachers as well as
stipends for food service and not a lot
but reasonable amount because let's be
honest I mean teachers aren't there to
deal with food waste they're there to
teach but if it's done properly as we as
we're showing it can be involved sort of
in the curriculum right because food
waste if you think about it is physics
biology and chemistry right conversion
of the food waste into energy that's
that's mechanical energy the breakdown
of composting that's biology methane
into the atmosphere that's chemistry so
if you can integrate that into into some
degree into the curriculum
um then becomes more complementary so
yeah the money we spent on equipment
uh hauling away of the food waste
miscellaneous expenses like garbage bags
which believe it or not you end up
getting a lot of
um and then probably some sort of a uh
you know like an uh a fee for someone to
come in and to administer it because the
teachers don't have a ton of time to do
this right they need help so you're
going to need somebody that's going to
need to kind of roam work with the
teachers work with the food service
Personnel uh get things going the reason
I say all this is because they are doing
this in housing board and such a a
beautiful way some you know they've
granted the city of hamiltonborg has a
fairly good sized staff but they have
people dedicated to to this and as a
result their their numbers are just gone
down dramatically thank you any other
questions from the committee
representative thank you I'm sorry yeah
thank you thank you madam chair thank
you for taking my question I was could
you speak a little bit more about in
particular about so food tracking that
you were referring to Yes it seems to be
particularly
um a lot of potential here right because
not only are you reducing the amount of
waste that that you're creating that's
going to save money uh but also for
schools for example especially at times
when prices are are as high as they are
now there's information that can be
gleaned from that process of food
tracking right so that that you can
order uh in ways for institutions that
will reduce costs in the front end in
terms of purchasing and I imagine that's
the kind of thing that people could
apply for Grants to be able to set up
systems to do that so can you say a
little bit more about the specific
example of food tracking and how you see
that yes of being built up so I mean the
people on I mean Tara is she's a
environmental teacher so she's very
unique she's dedicated to what she's
doing so she spends a good amount of
time most other teachers would be doing
this but you could do a modified version
of the food tracker but the food truck
trackers there too is there because it's
it's basically manage what you measure
you can manage what you actually measure
and so if you know the breakdown of food
and milk and various components you can
then take that that sheet and work with
food service and they can in turn look
at that and say okay I'm realizing that
we served x amount of lunches today and
we had x amount of waste today why is
that get more into detail and so and I
take this uh you know from my from my
colleagues in Sweden they've actually
designed a program where they give
certificates out to the Food Service
Personnel they actually can give them
certificates based on how well they
prepare sustainable meals meaning
all right let's let's keep me in there
but let's reduce it and get more
vegetables and things of that nature
reduce the CO2 footprint get more Local
Foods in make the food better you know
make the food better and and have less
waste and the kids and the food service
people really kind of all working
together and you start to get this this
uh symbiosis going and um before you
know it you know you're just seeing
waste numbers come dramatically down as
a result so all I'm going to say about
the food tracker is it's not meant to be
Overkill because again teachers don't
have all time to enter unless
information but things like the waste
per day then things like the waste per
student you kind of want to track some
some key metrics but in general
WWF gave us the the funding because they
felt we could do about 14 percent less
year over year that was sort of the goal
yep any other questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony this morning
welcome again and uh you have three
thank you I think I'll take less time
than that
um I'm I'm just here to say that our
town would welcome any funds from
anywhere including Manna From Heaven as
as representative evil said I described
our work song Farm drop-off program they
can only take so much and manage so much
at a farm if we were to expand this to a
town-wide program probably using our
transfer station we have no
infrastructure our staff is pretty much
full-time busy with what they do already
and if you're going to compost there are
a lot of different ways to do it but any
way you do it you have to do it right so
we would want to send our staff to the
main composting school we might need
more equipment we might need to fund
more staff hours so anyway we hope that
this would be a step in that direction
thank you thank you very much any
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you
all right then
I have no more pink cards is there
anybody else who wishes to speak
oh yeah
I have a question for representative
evil if I can sure if you would not mind
a question
from representative Creighton
I actually don't have a good source for
Manna From Heaven but
I could work on it mana.com I think you
can go there
so thank you very much for for coming up
for an additional question and as I
listen to the testimony I'm just trying
to
clarify my head so it's two million
bucks
and that Mill and that money comes from
where
is that is that the solicited grants or
is that state funding that goes into
that two million bucks okay so just to
just to clarify
um this is a two-step process so this is
the policy committee and you folks would
decide whether you agree with the tweaks
to the use of the management fund and if
you do and you make that recommendation
for Passage would go to the house if the
house passes it then it would go to the
finance committee and then when it goes
to the finance committee
um they would look at the overall budget
and they would decide how much money to
put into the fund so I'm when I wrote
the Bill I requested two million dollars
they could put in 5 million plus a
little Manna From Heaven or they could
put in five hundred thousand dollars but
it would at this point be coming from
General funds unless I'm missing another
source that the finance committee might
be able to tap into
so again this is a policy decision on on
your part whether you support this
amendment of the fund language and then
it would be the finance committee that
determines whether and how much to fund
it
okay thank you thank you thank you very
much
I am reading on the blue sheet first of
all any other people who wish to testify
because we have no more pink cards nope
seeing none thank you okay we had on our
blue sheet eight people sign in uh in
favor of this bill and zero against and
said they support and two people who
were against so
with that I will end the hearing on HB
462. thank you very much we are going to
break for lunch and we will be back here
at one o'clock
to continue hearings for this afternoon
we will start off at one o'clock with HB
494. thank you very much for your
attention
um
okay
good afternoon I'd like to bring our
meeting to order for a house environment
and agriculture committee
and I will open the uh
hearing for HB 494 which is relative to
fees collected under the New Hampshire
fertilizer law
and with us this afternoon to introduce
this bill is representative Peter Bixby
who is the Prime sponsor welcome
representative Bixby thank you it's been
so long since I've been to this
committee
so for the record my name is Peter Bixby
Dover New Hampshire Stafford 13. of
and this bill comes as a recommendation
uh from the study committee that we did
last fall on soil conditioners and
currently revenues from fertilizer
product registrations lime product
registration and fertilizer tonnage fees
are deposited into the general fund
and there is no guarantee that those
fees will get used to oversee the
fertilizer quality or even an
agricultural purpose
so this uh just a background on the way
some Financial stuff works in in the uh
in New Hampshire uh probably not up to
you know what someone in Ways and Means
would consider you know the appropriate
academic standards but roughly speaking
the status of fees is not really
addressed in the state constitution uh
but the uh for taxes it's clear that
taxes need to be reasonable reasonable
and proportional uh
and uh organizations that study uh
governmental record Revenue like the tax
Foundation distinguished between fees
and taxes in terms of uh what the base
of payers is for it and what the purpose
is uh taxes are for General General
governmental purposes uh and are
generally paid by a broadly defined base
fees are levied on a narrow base and
they provide services for that base
uh one of the
so
um one of the ways to ensure that fees
get used for the intended purposes is to
put the revenue into a fund for that
purpose
uh currently that's not what that's not
what's happening with the uh funds from
the from the revenues from the
fertilizer fees uh currently those go to
the general to the general fund and that
is almost like uh turning that fee into
a tax because it could be conceivably
used for any purpose at all in the state
government
said one one way of thinking about this
which I don't entirely agree with is
that if the fees in the general fund are
then
appropriated back to the agency that
that charged the fees then it still
counts as a fee rather than a tax but
there's really no way to ensure that the
department uh will necessarily get those
fees back or that when they get it back
it will be used for that intended
purpose uh the department is
so the uh the top
so uh the Department of Agriculture is
required to analyze a representative
sample of fertilizers sold each year to
ensure that they meet label
specifications
however we heard last year in testimony
in the soil uh
conditioner study that only two batches
of fertilizer were tested in the past in
that year and that the testing came only
in response to complaints that uh it
might have been substandard
um one reason that less testing was done
was probably that the department was
using a lot of personnel time to
administer a completely different
program
a program that is fortunately actually
not being dealt with by the department
anymore but
um that program had a free fee structure
which didn't come anywhere near meeting
the uh funding requirements for it so
essentially this the some of the fees
from that were going to the general fund
and then back into the department
um appropriation were not getting used
to do the job of the fertilizer fees but
to the do the job of the organic program
uh so the sub our study committee felt
that redirecting uh the revenue from
chapter 431 which is the the fertilizer
fund uh it's fertilizer chapter two a
dedicated fund uh that will pay for the
cost of administering that chapter uh
would be more consistent with the ways
fees should be handled and would
eliminate the possibility that the fees
were a disappoint disproportionate tax
and I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you representative Bixby any
representative Murray
thank you madam chair for taking my
question uh representative Bixby can you
explain uh for those who might be new to
the committee the difference between
lapsing and non-lapsing funds
uh so
um
not as well as someone on Ways and Means
could but uh basically a non-lap sync
fund is a fund that
uh the fund continues to exist uh
whether or not there's been more
Appropriations to it whereas a lapsing
fund basically it
it disappears as soon as uh the the the
funding for it dries up and it does and
it doesn't um it doesn't continue to
exist
sure representative Murray go ahead
thank you and then to that end is there
a cap on
to that uh I did not I did not in this
bill put a uh cap on uh how much the
fund could uh accrue to I suspect that's
not going to be an issue given that uh
the
um
and the the amount of money that is
required for uh the Personnel that to uh
to administer the in chapter 431
plus the
um maintenance requirements for with any
luck we'll be getting a uh data
processing system for uh the department
and um so the combination of the costs
for the Personnel their space their
materials and uh the data processing is
probably enough to at least exhaust the
any other questions from the committee
seeing none oh I have one more comment
on which is that back when we were doing
the study one of the members of the
committee suggested that we might need
to consider raising the the fee a little
bit uh by a nominal amount uh and I did
did get give that some consideration and
because with the new data processing we
don't we won't really know what the
needs are for the in that degree of
specificity I thought that it would be
best to leave the fees as they are
representative knabb
um thank you representative is there
um would it be beneficial to say that
the fee is set by the commissioner as
you've done in previous no the fee is
actually set in statute and it is uh I
believe it's 75 dollars for uh per
fertilizer registration which is based
on the uh grade of the fertilizer in the
brand and it is I think fifty dollars uh
for the grade and brand of of lime and
then there is a tonnage fee uh which is
basically a per ton fee and I don't
remember how much that is but it's not
thank you representative Bixby any other
questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
and now I would like to call
commissioner Sean Jasper Department of
Agriculture
good afternoon good afternoon Madam
chairman members of the committee I am
Sean Jasper commissioner of the
Department of agricultural markets and
food uh appear in support of the bill I
think that representative Bixby covered
the subject matter very well and I thank
him for submitting submitting the bill
on behalf of the uh committee that met
last year and I will attempt to answer
foreign
so for the funds that have been
collected so far for this
um
for registration of fertilizer and so
forth
that those funds have been put in the
general fund
how has Department of Agriculture
accessed any of that money through the
budget process so as I told you I don't
know a couple weeks ago now I guess it
was that we essentially produce more
Revenue than we are required that is
required to run the department and that
does range from 200 000 to a million in
any given fiscal year
and so we do have to put in our budget
request this wouldn't change that
calculus because a lot of money comes in
from
pesticides as well and so it would not
put us into a situation where we were
now keeping more money in this fund and
representative Bixby is correct that it
costs more to run the division of
regulatory Services then this bill would
um
bring in but I think it does make it a
lot easier for us to to justify the
division it'll allow us to really
ensure the stability
um you know when we went through budget
cuts in previous years that's when
programs started to be reduced because
we did lose Personnel back in
2010-11 in that in that era and um
having the stability of a dedicated fund
prevents that type of thing from
happening and when it comes to the
protection that we provide to Farmers I
think it's more important to have that
type of stability than it is to say okay
well this is where we're going to look
to to cut because we are as I've told
you largely Consumer Protection Agency
so have you had to in the past
ask for the money that
was give was given in these fees did you
track how much the fees were coming we
always track track the fees I don't have
that number with me but we do provide
that
that information in in the budget again
showing that depending on the variable
um the variance is that we always do
turn more money back to the general fund
that includes this this would just mean
that ultimately we would be requesting
less from the general fund moving
forward
and one further question from me uh
because I'm not familiar with that piece
of the budgeting process is
um
so now with this in place
you would be able to draw funds directly
from this fund to do uh to run the
program and we do have fun uh funds
primarily it's called the
scale testing product and scale testing
fund which does give us we still submit
the budgetary information but it gives
us greater flexibility when there is is
a need because in
a percentage of our the money we bring
in goes directly to the general fund and
the rest stays in the fee in the funds
and the two primarily primary
um funds or that product testing which
money from
uh from these products currently is is
going into a fund and then we have the
uh
integrated Pest Management fund which
was recently changed to allow us to also
pay for personnel that that fund was
building up a surplus and rather than
change that calculus it was better to
request less funds from the general fund
and take more from where the the
revenues were being generated because as
representative Bixby said there can be a
fine line between a tax and a fee
um fees are not supposed to generate
more than 125 percent of the cost of
running the program and that calculus is
a little bit more difficult when monies
are going hither and young rather than
just coming into the area where they're
being spent
um
and one one final question for me about
how many other dedicated funds do you
have from the Department
currently there are a number of very
tiny ones I don't know how many there
are just two primary funds currently the
other ones are related to organic
programs and to
a few other little things but those are
not significant we're talking perhaps
tens of thousands of dollars we are as
of January 1st we have been allowed to
take the monies that come in from fines
put them into a a fund which is a
revolving fund but we can't use more
than 75 000 a year to hire someone to
actually deal with our
um
uh hearing cases all of the fines that
we issued when we have to have hearings
because we have been way behind on that
so that is a new new fund but that is
just capped at a use of 75 000 per year
okay thank you so much any questions
from the committee representative
Compton
thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner for taking my question
um
in listening to representative bixby's
testimony
um and only testing fertilizer twice
last year
um and fertilizer is an important
component to agriculture in this state
would you say that we are doing the
state a disservice by not testing more
frequently
there's no question in my mind but that
we are doing the the farms and farmers
and anyone using commercial
um
fertilizer a disservice we should be
doing more we want to do more and
hopefully this will allow us to do more
representative datsey yes thank you
madam chair and thank you commissioner
uh as a little bit of a follow-up to
that uh in the original bill was is
there was there a testing protocol that
was outlined in other words I would have
assumed that like you know every one ton
or something like that what it what is
that
sorry that I'm not totally prepared for
I
there is a protocol in place
right now the two tests we did last year
were at the request and I don't think
that is the way it is supposed to work
but because we haven't gotten back into
that mode that's not something that's uh
really in my mind but it is it is
totally separate from from this
representative Creighton
all right thank you madam chair uh thank
you sir I appreciate your testimony in
in your grasp of this I
didn't let me just
say something and tell me how far off I
am okay so
in essence what this bill says is that
the 385
000 that you've collected
that's gone into the general fund will
it's that is true not quite that that
simple because
um you know we have been getting the
amount we requested from the general
fund recently
so you know money is going back and
forth the problem becomes if somebody
decides okay we need a couple hundred
thousand here
it would be very easy just to
not fund our positions which is what has
happened in the past and we only you
know recently really got well I
shouldn't even say we're back to full
Staffing I think we are I think in the
last budget we actually finally had all
of our uh
positions that had been cut and
the 1011 budget 11 whatever whatever the
years were I think we just finally got
back to there because that's what
happened
because they were seen as general fund
now the legislature always has the power
to come in and sweep our accounts
but generally generally when the the
people with their eyes on those accounts
are looking at them they're looking for
funds in the millions not in the
hundreds of thousands so
small funds are generally a little
better protected unless we really get
into
Dire Straits and then of course I think
any other questions from the committee
seeing none there are no other pink
cards so if anybody else would like to
make any comment please let yourself be
known
online we had one
thank you
and we have one person in support of
this bill and three people written on
yeah okay and with that I'm going to
close the hearing on HB 494
and we will begin hearing on HB 326
um in about seven minutes
um at 1 30. so we'll take a little bit
do I need to refresh this
no
foreign
okay it is
131 in the afternoon I am
going to open up the hearing that we
have for HB 326 prohibiting the use of
second generation anticoagulant
rodenticides
and here with us today
to introduce the bill is representative
Jerry Cannon
and welcome to environment and
agriculture thank you for the invitation
um
Madam chair fellow members of the of the
committee and in the State House
um I'm here before you to talk about
something that I didn't know anything
about until this past
six months
we all know that New Hampshire is is
tourists playground
we have plenty of things to do
and
when we think about it people come here
to ski to swim to hike
and a lot of people come to take
photographs
of our wildlife
um
the birds
the the Bears the
uh the many forms that we have
um in in our mountains and in our
communities
um even just down the
the street for me along the river
between us and Maine we have some bald
eagles and they're really impressive to
this is what people come to New
Hampshire for
especially in the fall let's see the
foliage
what would happen
if we lost
and I say that because this bill isn't
just about rodents
it's about all of our wildlife and
especially that our carnivores or the
you're going to hear from a number of
folks today that have more knowledge
than I on on the topic as well as
experience of working with our Wildlife
especially our Raptors
um and the horrifying things that I've
are raptors and many of the animals that
prey on rodents
they take care of the rodents
the challenge is is that we're poisoning
their diet
and that one of the primary culprits are
the second generation anticoagulant
rodentsides
our native Wildlife predators are really
a public Trust
their nature they do this they maintain
well the rodents that we have are food
for our wildlife
especially our Birds prey
we know that they damage our property
and Food Supplies
to combat these
even I needed toxins this past this past
few months I had a couple of rats in my
own home and had to go down to Home
Depot and see what they had
I couldn't catch them in my have a heart
trap so I needed something else
there were plenty erotic sites on the
Shelf
as I checked them there there were no
escars as we referred to them
on any of those products but there were
some anticoagulant drugs that are in the
in the products that consumers can use
it only took two to three days before I
caught
and killed all the rats in my home
thankfully my dogs cornered one of them
so it was a natural progression they
were able to have them hunt them down I
was glad they didn't have to take a bite
of them
and
catch any poisons that might have been
ingested by the rat before they caught
them
the most recent varieties of these these
toxins
are these
second generation anticoagulant rodent
sites
and I say this because
typically when we poison a rat or a
mouse or anything is that the shelf life
the
of that poison is typically just in the
rat and by the time they die it's not
it's not
um critical for any animal that that
eats it
but the second generation
rodentsides are
have a have a uh a life of about 100
days or more
in that creature that has died and now
is available for any any creature that
comes across a dead rat and says and you
know it's it's just a natural thing to
eat eat that right rat and it's actually
very easy prey
for our Raptors because they're they're
not moving
and that's one of the problems we have
is that a road that a Raptor
um whose primary diet has these rodents
is going to pick up these these rodents
and take it back to their nest and
they're going to eat it and possibly
feed it to their young
or an ingesting this this poison they
would be poisoning the eggs that they
I have to cons have to consider the rat
this is a terrible way for these
creatures to die
um because the anticoagulant
wrote inside
essentially it if they if they start to
bleed this they just bleed out
or
it's going they're going to bleed inside
causing them great pain and they will
die that way
there are other methods
that we can use
to kill the rats
capture the rats there are traps there
are other there the med the thing I
bought from uh Home Depot
it is a good product and it does kill a
you find that there have been studies
from unh
and they found rodentsides in in a very
high percentage of the animals tested
not just
the rodent sides
that have been used they lead to direct
mortality and chronic long-term Health
impacts for natural predators
and non-target organisms and even our
one of the things that I saw on the
label of the product was to flag that
there was a problem for
non-target species
and I was trying to figure out from a
conservative standpoint
that's what it stated there but does a
in these asgards although they're not
available currently in the in the FDA
has has flagged them is not acceptable
for Consumer use
are still being used by by many licensed
professionals
this bill
doesn't completely eliminate escars
it does reduce the amount of places
that they can be used
and including areas where there is an
infestation of rats but hasn't been able
to control with conventional products
these are dangerous products
it's sort of like
throwing a defoliant on your on your
lawn to kill
crabgrass but instead you're killing the
entire
grasp and have to deal with replanting
the whole thing the problem is is that
we're killing off our wildlife
it's not just the rats it's anything
that eats them
and sadly we have to think about the
future for our our wildlife
I plead with you
to vote ought to pass on this this bill
so we can save our state wildlife
thank you
thank you representative Cannon any
questions from the committee
representative knabb
thank you madam chair
um you said you just started researching
this about six months ago what triggered
you working on this legislation
I went to on the wing in Epping which
many of you may have seen
um from the New Hampshire uh
just throw a blank
but you'll hear some folks that have
have been uh uh have been in
organizations that are essentially
caring for these Raptors I saw a number
of rap beautiful birds snowy white owl
actually the one that I saw I learned it
had been poisoned they had it recovered
and was back for a second time and as it
was flagged to me is that he said that
owl just is not right anymore
um it's affected their brain
they were Hawks
they were Eagles
they were quite a number of animals
there
and one of the statistics that they
shared was
of the birds that come to this
to their Clinic
only about 30 percent of the birds that
were able to save
um
to see these beautiful creatures
and then to learn about
why they were there
it really it hurt
I said because this is a man-made
problem
that we have done this
to make it easy for us to kill something
in our homes
or in the community we have created this
problem
and that's what the light dawned I I got
to speak up on this because that's
painful
any other questions from the committee
thank you representative Cannon
um I appreciate your testimony this
afternoon thank you now I'd like to call
commissioner Sean Jasper from the
Department of Agriculture to come and
speak
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee I am Sean Jasper commissioner
of the Department of Agriculture markets
and food
I'm here to testify in opposition to the
bill
and not because I'm not
concerned about
wildlife and what may be happening
but because we have a process
in-state statute
that allows us to look at this without
tugging at the emotions and using actual
research not just
testimony that
that points to a a problem but without
the scientific information behind it we
have been looking at this issue I chair
the pesticide control board which is
charged by Statute with looking at the
uses of of pesticides and what the
effects are and the proper way to deal
with this is to let us scientifically
look at the problem as a matter of fact
the governor has brought this to our
attention because he was believing that
this was an immediate problem that we
needed to do something we've been able
to show him the evidence that
leads us to believe at this at this
point there may be other issues
some of you will remember a few years
ago we had a bill about pesticides being
the problem for
be die off
and in in fact what the evidence is is
showing is that it's mites some of it is
related to the global warming where on
warm days like we had a couple of weeks
ago the bees wake up they go out looking
for food they don't find any they go
into other hives that may be infected
have not been treated they bring it back
and and the hives die
we are testing birds that that have died
at this point
um in New Hampshire there has been have
been
none that have been shown to have died
by ingesting
um this material in Massachusetts there
has been one
but that in fact was a case where the
um rodenticide was not properly put out
in the bird ingested that directly that
obviously should not happen
and that's a a problem potentially we
received
um a report this past
summer fall that led to some of this
where there was this belief that there
was a huge problem I believe it was in
the Hampton area
we immediately sent inspectors over to
investigate to try to collect
um the dead birds
nothing
came of it it was an exaggeration
so I'm not here to tell you that there
isn't a problem
I'm not here to tell you that there is a
problem
I'm telling you that we are looking at
it and that the evidence should be
brought to the pesticide control board
for us to look at it to follow that that
process because we are all concerned
about that but please don't override the
process that the legislature has has put
in place director Russo is here to uh to
speak to this he has a lot more
knowledge on the details than I do so
I'd ask you not to ask me questions
about the science behind it I am not a
scientist
um
but we have concerns we are working with
fish and game as a under the directive
of the governor to look at this Pro
problem and to come back to him with a
report on what our findings are I think
it's very important not to overreact not
to just assume we need to see the the
pathology behind this we need to have
the necropsies of these birds to show
what in fact has has killed them before
we go to this step because let's not
pretend that rats are nice little
creatures
they're not you know and they're one
thing if they're out
perhaps
um you know in the wild they're another
thing if we find them in the cities
where rat populations can grow you know
very very rapidly and I think we've all
seen you know thankfully not in New
Hampshire but I think we've seen stories
over the years about you know children
babies in in some of our more congested
cities being you know bitten
by rats they are not our friends they're
never going to be our friends and we
need to make sure that we protect people
from what rats can do to them and to
um
to our environment in general
um they're not a clean nice animal so
um
listen to the care to the testimony
carefully but know we are working at it
know that we want to uh we we have the
authority to ban this
um if in fact it is found to be the
problem legislation is not needed we
already have that Authority Under the
pesticide control board
oh thank you any questions from the
thank you commissioner
um
so my question is just to um is I guess
just a further clarification and what
you said that at this point
um there is no problem that you've found
correct so how many am like if you just
just a basic how many how many birds or
um you know Foxes or anything else or
that have you tested I think there are
those behind me who will be testifying
that can answer your question better
to the makeup of the pesticide control
board
we have I think
perhaps director Russo can speak to that
we do have citizen members we have
members from
many different
um
areas of expertise but David Russo can
speak to that more directly I don't have
that off the top of my head but I he
works with it all the time so I think
you can answer that very completely
representative germana
thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner
um I don't think this is a science
question but if it crosses that line
then you know I can ask it if someone
else but uh first of all I want to say I
appreciate and very sensitive to when we
make changes we have to make changes
based on evidence so I appreciate you
know your comments about that uh this
afternoon my question is is this
hopefully I can make it clear uh given
all of the other methods that we have of
of
um dealing with with the rat population
right
um how what would be the the larger
impact If This Were to pass for example
right so given other methods are we
talking about this does something that
is so important that it fills a niche
which is so important in our strategy
and dealing with the rat population that
if we only relied upon other methods of
of control that we would be leaving
ourselves in a precarious situation
don't want to try to pass it off but I
will to a larger degree because
there are certainly evidence relative to
the knee I mean once once you find
something that is very effective
nobody really puts more research into
how do we kill something better
so just intuitively I'm going to tell
you that what's been out there has not
been as effective as we would like it to
be or would not have been Advanced but
again I think that there will be those
who can answer that more more
scientifically but as far as I know
there would be a negative impact where
we to to ban this
thank you madam chair and thank you
commissioner for taking my question in
the agricultural industry
um there has been an uptick in rodents
um especially large rats uh infiltrating
Farms if we were to ban anything that
could help with that what would happen
to the agricultural industry if we had
an overrun of the rodent population
I'm afraid it would be negative
um you know rats are carriers of disease
and um you know they can carry some
pretty serious diseases and when they
bite which if they are hungry they will
um
you know I can't really tell you what
those results would be but it would be
negative
so I that's why we need to look at this
very carefully because there are always
trade-offs
and we have to weigh the the negatives
and the positives of doing something
like this but the pesticide control
board is not afraid of of banning things
which have negative consequences to our
environment and potentially this does
representative Murray thank you madam
chair uh thank you commissioner for
taking my question I am curious I think
it was testified too that uh it I
believe unh
um
had found rodenticides have they brought
that before the uh with you as the chair
of this have they they have they have
not and
I believe that
okay
but but we didn't get anything
okay just sorry about that just wanna so
there has been some information that
that has come through fish and game on
that I don't know where it came from but
I you know we work with uh Cooperative
Extension and
um in UNH quite closely but it if it
wasn't Cooperative Extension it was
somebody else they may not have brought
it to us but certainly I have seen no
research
that has UNH attached to it
any other questions from the committee
no thank you commissioner Jasper and now
I'd like to call Carol Foss from New
you've asked for three minutes to speak
and you are suggesting an amendment
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee I'm hoping I can do
this in three minutes so I I might have
been a little conservative there
um there's no question that rodents are
or infestations of rodents can be a
major inexpensive problem
um there's also no question that some of
the chemicals that are used to
address rodent
infestations cause major problems for
some New Hampshire wildlife
Andy coagulant rodenticide's work by
interfering with the
blood clotting process in the body
um first generation rodenticides include
the Coumadin that many of us may be
taking
um
second generation rodenticides are much
more potent and whereas the first
generation chemicals may it may take
several meals of The Poisoned bait in
order for an animal to succumb with the
second generation rodenticides
animals typically die after a single
meal from the bait
um
in either case mice and rats that have
eaten these poisons can live for several
days and during that time they're kind
of running around in the environment
where they can be easy prey for Hawks
owls fissures foxes and other predators
of small mammals
um
there was some reference to tests at UNH
and the veterinary Diagnostic lab at UNH
um tested 35 fur-bearing animals
including I believe foxes Fishers well
both red and gray foxes and Fishers from
24 New Hampshire towns in 2019 to 2020
and found the second generation a
residues of the second generation
rodenticides in all but one individual
so it's out there in our in our
environment it's getting into
um Wildlife predators
um necropsies of birds of prey in New
England have found high concentrations
of these chemicals
um
so there are some concerns about how
effective
the proposed ban would be in addressing
the wildlife problems
um
the exceptions to the proposed ban
certainly provide ample opportunity for
poisoned mice and rats to get out there
the
United States Environmental Protection
Agency has recognized the risks
associated with these chemicals and is
currently in the process of developing
mitigation measures specifically to
address concerns with federally listed
threatened and endangered species
um
and what we would like to suggest is
that this will be amended to authorize a
working group that would convene the
various stakeholders in this issue
including representatives of New
Hampshire licensed pesticide applicators
division of Public Public Health
Services the division of pesticide
control division of AG markets and Foods
New Hampshire Fish and Game
the diagnostic Veterinary Lab at UNH
licensed New Hampshire rehabilitators
a New Hampshire Audubon and this group
could really address the science
investigate the seasonal and geographic
distribution of
significant rodent infestations in New
Hampshire
I don't think anybody really has a
handle on that from a Statewide
perspective
um
look at the current frequency duration
type and geographic distribution of
rodenticide applications in New
Hampshire because most of these
applications one would hope all are
being made by licensed professionals
um
and assess the likelihood that the EPA
mitigation measures will be sufficient
to address New Hampshire's speech
Wildlife species of conservation concern
and identify any additional mitigation
measures that might be appropriate in
New Hampshire
so with that I will thank you for your
attention and close my testimony
questions from the committee
representative Bixby
yes uh just for uh to clarify
is your Amendment on for the for a work
uh our working group would that replace
the ban or would that be in addition to
the ban
that would be up to you folks I I I'm as
the person requesting it I'm I'm my
question to you is if in your ideal
world would that working group uh be
would there be a ban as well as the
working group or would would the working
group basically help figure out if we
we're not against the ban but we
recognize that there are that there
there are a lot of sides to this issue
and
um
we would like to see a scientific
approach taken to really understand the
big picture
um
and where where are the major rat issues
in New Hampshire
um how are they being addressed but just
get everyone get all the stakeholders
around the table and try and come up
with with an approach that is acceptable
to everybody okay thank you thank you
any other questions representative
Creighton
thank you Matt thank you madam chair and
ma'am great great testimony I'm just I
want to clarify
what what do you see the difference
between the department of agriculture's
poison commission and your proposed
group that would also look at the same
thing it seems like it's to my knowledge
the pesticides board does not have a
representation from the veterinary
Diagnostics Lab at UNH for example from
wildlife rehabilitators
um
from our organization
I guess there is someone on there from
fish and game
follow up so the mission would be the
same but the makeup will be different
well I think the mission would be
a little broader to do more
Research into
where
how often at what time of year what are
the patterns of rodent infestations in
the state
I think that goes a little beyond the
um
the the usual business of the pesticides
board
um it would be it would be kind of a
study group to really look into
all aspects of the problem
and also to evaluate how the EPA
mitigation measures that are supposed to
be coming out later this year
how effective would those be in
protecting New Hampshire species of
conservation concern okay thank you
ma'am
any other questions oh representative
Bixby yes so would you see the working
group as essentially
something that would be working in in
conjunction with the pesticide control
board in order to provide them with the
broader range of evidence they need in
order to make an appropriate judgment as
opposed to something that would be
working either in parallel or even like
in contradiction to them
I mean I guess my vision would be that
this working group would would prepare a
report and I think that the pesticides
control board would be an excellent
recipient of that report
because they would be they would be in
the position to act on it if
recommendations
were put forth
representative Bixby so essentially
you'd see the working group as as a way
of supporting the work of the control
board in in order to find a the most
accurate
um
uh approach to this problem
it's a reasonable way of putting it yes
any other questions from the committee
being none thank you very much for your
testimony
I'd like to call David Rousseau from New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture
good afternoon thank you I'm David
Rousseau with New Hampshire Department
of Agriculture markets and food I'm the
director of the division of pesticide
control and with me is Robert bruly
Robert is a an environmentalist with
division of pesticide control and he
also has an advanced degree in uh in
wildlife biology I think one of the
things that will help to this discussion
on the last page of the the letter that
the department had provided it
identifies the chemical types of
rodenticides there are and I think it
will help in this discussion to sort of
take a look at that there's um really
two groups
of rodenticides in regard to chemistry
there's a first generation anticoagulant
and those were pretty much
pre-1970s we have War firing on that
list
chlorophysinone and diphosinone again
pre-70s they weren't called first
generation when they when they came out
what pushed them into that designation
was the second generation anticoagulants
but it needs a rodenticide is a
pesticide and it's used to control
rodents a coagulant refers to normal
blood clotting an anticoagulant refers
to in this conversation is it controls
Road rodents by disrupting blood
clotting okay so that's what we're
talking about in regard to coagulant
anticoagulant so these first generation
anticoagulants that became a resistance
the animals were resistant to those
materials and that's why we have the
second generation come about and that
includes the Roto vacuum the broader
dialogue the diphythylon and the
diphunaculum so those second generation
anticoagulants was 1970s
um and we should we've been using them
since um and then we have the
non-anticoagulants and that includes
bromophilin
Cola calciferol and the zinc phosphide
now all these three groups currently are
being reviewed by the United States
Environmental Protection Agency the
United States Environmental Protection
Protection Agency requires manufactures
of pesticides to satisfy certain
standards how that chemical will react
in the environment what its impact might
be to the human health
there's a number of standards that come
into play and if that company the
manufacturer identifies or satisfies
those standards then those products
become available so these products that
we're talking about today the the ones
on the list that I just identified are
all identified by the the federal
government as being appropriate for use
when using accordance with their label
now EPA as mentioned in this discussion
there is some preliminary
intermediate preliminary decisions on
how to further restrict all three groups
so that we we don't have this this
concern this this this this challenge
with the residue and animals the
department is no shape in form saying
that we don't recognize that there is
residue of these materials in animals
birds and mammals there's no there's no
doubt that that exists and I appreciate
the the the bill from representative
canon in identifying that that that's a
concern it's a concern that we have
um and the federal government right now
is trying is trying to address that in
in November they released a document in
regards to their proposal and again
they're proposing further restrictions
on these materials their public comment
period will end in February from for the
U.S in United Environmental Protection
Agency and then they'll begin their
their action as far as what the
restrictions how they'll pan out over
the next year
um so again United States Environmental
Protection Agency requires manufacturers
to of pesticides to satisfy certain
standards
um
okay one of the question was asked about
did we receive information from the
United States uh from the University of
New Hampshire uh vet lab we did receive
them but through the
um uh New Hampshire Fish and Game did a
study on animals that were
received through hunting not not through
through
um uh contamination of a pesticide but
just to see if those animals had these
um residues in in them and they did and
and I think a 34 out of 36 of those
animals identified as having residue
um rodenticide residue in them but they
weren't that's not what what led them to
their demise they were provided as as
part of a study another important piece
while we're talking about that is to
really understand how that residue gets
into the animal and actually overwhelms
the animal or the bird to to terminate
it requires an intensive internal organ
um review uh study
kidney I'm pretty sure it's a kidney
um and so it's a scientific clinical
approach to really identify that that's
exactly what is the reason why an animal
would be terminated from that not
doubting that the residue is there the
residue is there pretty much any bird or
animal that's eating a rat or or a mouse
is is more than likely going to get this
residue
um inside them
so I mentioned the wildlife activity
Federal View and we do have rodent
concerns
um we have the division of pesticide
control has received an increase of Road
and concern calls over the last 10 years
mainly rats
um so these these products are important
to that control
now our Focus division of pesticide
control is pesticides it's the chemical
piece but in our training in our
training materials
um we always identify other methods so
we don't just talk about the chemicals
we talk about trapping we talk about
mechanical controls patching holes
picking up trash and things like that so
that's all part of this control pieces
and it should be we shouldn't just be
talking about chemical when we're
talking about Road and control so that
education piece needs to continue
um and then there was a question about
the pesticide control board there are 13
members by Statute
um the active members are listed on that
letter right now and you'll see the name
and then the department or the their
interest
um there are some members that are not
on there right now that were in in
seeking out to fill and that includes uh
two public seats and there is one that
uh showed interest and that's moving
ahead there's one that should be there
on the representing Municipal interest
that's not on there the medical doctor
is the toughest one for us to keep on
the board and I I don't know if they've
it's just been a difficult position to
keep so that you won't see that um
filled right now so outside of those
four or five positions there are eight
active members currently
um and and again the Boyd has that
function of reviewing pesticides and
making decisions is whether they'd be
further restricted and to that point in
the pesticide board's rules the
administrative rules of New Hampshire
there is a section to put
products or pesticide active ingredients
when they become restricted so there's
actually a a chapter within the rules
itself it's PES 700 but we do have a
list of products that are restricted
beyond the federal government we also
have a listing of products that are
banned or active ingredients that are
banned uh well let's it's identified as
prohibited in in the list
um I think that's it I there was one
other question that was asked I thought
oh the number of animals the makeup of
the board
um
the impact if we take away these
materials
there will be an impact but to put a
number on it or identify I I don't I
don't know
um
the that's that's that's all I have
right now
yeah
blurry of hands representative Murray
new Madam chair for taking my question
crash fishing game you mentioned that
the original 34 out of the 36 animals
that had tested positive for the residue
um met their demise some other way part
of what I'm also thinking about is
obviously fish and game has jurisdiction
over hunting
um so to what degree this these
if if this is happening and
this is an animal that is being consumed
by the public and they're testing
positive for these things as well in
addition to all of the other
uh
residues that are being noticed in uh
eggs and all sorts of other
um
birds and and whether it's Offspring I I
know that
going back into the 16s and 70s when we
talked about DDT and things like that it
did transfer into the eggs and there
were significant problems with that
chemical so I guess what I'm what I'm
asking here is
um
what prompted the initial study and test
by Fish and Game to look for this
initially and and why I guess great
so this has been a concern for a number
of years and it's it's been tracked
by the United States Environmental
Protection Agency has increased their
restrictions on rodenticides over time
so the last group of restrictions we saw
was in 2008. so the studies keep
continue so different states different
organizations will will study residue
and and the impact and that's why we
have these recent lists
um of proposed restrictions from from
the Environmental Protection Agency it's
important to note when you bring up DDT
that DDT was a bio accumulator okay
these chemicals or not the the second
generation anticoagulants they're not
they don't get stronger or become a high
intensity in strength as they go from
organism to organism they do transfer we
know that
but they don't bioaccumulate and that's
an important piece so we shouldn't be
comparing the second generation
anticoagulanticides to DDT
um
I think that's all I have
Representatives Stuart um smart
oh I'm sorry uh Howard I'm looking at
the place my my apologies representative
Howard no problem thank you
um I I have three questions actually and
one of the the first one is um
and and I'll just ask them all in a row
and you can just answer them all
together the first one is um what would
be the harm in having this task force
that was suggested by the Audubon
Society
um and and maybe start a literature
review of the science that is out there
already because it sounds like
each of you are looking at different
parts of this of this existing science
um and also I wonder uh if uh why not
why not err on the side of caution and
bet and have a temporary ban while you
do the science in case you find out that
it is as lethal as or as harmful as as
the bill claims right
um and I guess there was only two
questions
the task force I think is a great great
suggestion and and a number of the
um uh Ms Foss had recommended uh
including the Diagnostic lab and some of
these rehabilitator folks and I think
that would work well
I would suggest that those individuals
on February 6 the Boyd has a meeting
February 6 9 30 room 201 approached the
Boyd
um I and that this topic is on the
board's agenda as it has been
rodenticide and and and we could we the
boy at the boards I'm not on the board
but they could at least listen to that
suggestion and and maybe come up with a
work group that would that would you
know could meet on a regular basis the
division division could certainly
facilitate the meetings we're willing to
do that the literature review it it is
um there is quite a bit out there
um and that's why I said we're not
denying that there's residue out there
is uh quite a bit of information as far
as
erring on the side of cautioning and
having a moratorium
again I think that's something that
should go through the board
um I know California has done has done
that on a number of these these second
generation anticoagulants I don't know
where they stand right now as far as
their experience with going to that
moratorium
um but that that's certainly a point to
consider
uh representative Davis
thank you madam chair and thank you Mr
Russo for taking my question
I'm just curious how they apply this is
it is it like a commercial
application or
yeah there's a number of different
products rodenticides probably the most
common ones
um from the for the commercial
applicator they usually use traps bait
traps and then and they fill those traps
with their they look like blocks like uh
broken pieces of chalk if you will fit
in a box about this size they put around
a structure the animal goes in there it
takes the debate and then and then you
know goes off and then the the homeowner
and what EPA has really tried to push to
do is get it in a a container that is a
one one one use only and it's not you're
not you shouldn't be fussing with the
blocks it's already in the container the
problem with that is
the internet in a big way that they they
we they have you can you can buy pretty
much anything that's that's available
that was intended to for example for an
agriculturist the farmer may buy
something in an 18 pound container that
is those blocks
um so that's pretty much what epa's
trying to focus on now is get that away
from the residential use by homeowners
so there's a number of delivery meth
methods there's the commercial
applicator that that uses that method I
identified as The Bait Box and there's a
homeowner that should only be using the
ones that are ready to use and throw
away type
um and and then there are some uh some
sure
I I want to touch on what representative
Murray had said if if this is uh
like animals are you tested 34 out of 36
they had residue how would that affect a
hunter that may not test the animal
shoot something and eat it uh something
that had that residue would how would
that affect a human
that's a great question and I um so the
residue is supposed to be at such a
level If the product pesticide was used
in the coins with this label uh properly
it shouldn't be a problem
but I would like to see some some
information on that some data and I
don't know if you have anything to add
Bob on that one no
yeah so it clearly gets transferred
um but uh but it depends on what part of
the the typical part that you're eating
in the animal anyway is not the internal
organs I know some people do eat them
but the the meat of it themselves that
shouldn't be transferred to for example
muscle or the the most common types of
meat that people will eat but I don't
know I can't give you any numbers with
that for sure all right thank you
representative NAB
thank you madam chair thank you
um do you know if any other states have
banned this
California is the only state that I'm
aware of that put a moratorium on it now
you will see in literature and online
that it's been banned but it's it's a
representative Murray
uh and the line of questioning there um
if there is this concern and I I know
you're speaking to the moratorium is
there someone from fish and game here
nope
okay
um is there an opportunity at Madam
chair what is the procedure if there are
questions to reach out to fish and game
uh well I guess we can uh ask the
committee researcher to find out some
information for us yep any other
questions representative germana thank
you madam chair uh thank you uh so I
appreciate I understand as you said
before you can't quantify what the
impact would be if we all of a sudden we
put a moratorium on this right if we
didn't use these products uh but I'm
wondering given the exceptions that are
listed in the bill right which include
agricultural production uh I'm wondering
if those exceptions would apply to a
significant number of important
applications of a pesticide like this so
if we're concerned about the impact on
the state's agriculture which of course
we should be that there are exceptions
for that here so do the exceptions
listed in the bill provide a significant
um
uh amount of these kinds of products
that are used in the state because
you're also speaking forward in answer
to representative Davis's first question
about the difference between commercial
application as opposed to something
somebody buys off uh off Amazon uh it
would seem to me in terms of commercial
application things like agricultural
production would make up a significant
amount of the usage of some of these
pesticides so what are these exceptions
do you think sufficient
one of the questions we had on the
agricultural exception it says an
agricultural food production site and so
is is that does that mean of any kind of
food that's being grown I I think that a
definition would be helpful as far as
what they mean by agricultural food
production site and the availability of
the products because it's also in that
same sentence as listed slaughterhouse
or Cannery so I don't know really how
this exception would would apply across
any other questions I oh representative
oh I'm sorry representative smart
I was I was just wondering if there was
a minimum efficacy dose for any of these
second Generations because like with the
majority of things
um there is a weight that you do your
dosage by so if we are
giving mice a dosage to kill a mouse
would not necessarily be a dose you know
like you you say you have animals with
residue in their system obviously it's
not enough to kill them so is there a
dosage I wasn't able to find one I was
able to find um
the percentage of what was in I'm
that that's my question
so the the manufacturer has to identify
to the federal government what dosage
that they recommend
I can speak to bromothalan which is a
non-anticoagulant but it represents the
level of of dosage and inactive
ingredient it's
.005 yeah and then that you know is is
very little how that transfers to if it
ended up an animal and we eat the animal
what that what that residue would be
like I don't I don't know
foreign Bixby
yes so um I'm wondering if there has
been uh you mentioned that with first
generation rodenticides there had been
evidence that uh the uh the rat
population was gaining resistance to
them and uh so I have a couple of
questions about that development of
resistance first of all
um is there evidence of resistance
developing for the second generation
anticoagulants and uh if there is that
gen if there is resistance developing in
the Target population of rats uh would
it be reasonable to expect that that
resistance would not develop in the rat
Predators who might eat them and then be
I'm not aware I'm sure there's studies
out there on Resistance from
to uh secondary anticoagulants
um I think that's an awesome question
about the animal that eats that prey
will they become resistant or does it is
it is it more of a um an impact
situation I I don't know I I don't know
thank you
okay I I have a question and then I'll
go to your representative.c so my
question is if if these substances were
banned
um would we have to resort to using more
toxic substances to eliminate
rodents
I would say more than likely because you
you're taking away the second generation
well the first generation is probably
not as toxic or but it but it takes more
dosing for the first generation so
they're around in the environment longer
than the second generation if people
don't have the second generation
anticoagulants and they jump to the
non-anticcoagulants some of the
non-integer wildlands are more toxic
than the second generation
do you have anything further oh go ahead
if I could speak um yeah so the first
generation anticoagulants
um as we heard before took several
feedings so that animal was exposed more
and more and so there was a buildup of
resistance uh as far as what we'd rely
on uh the uh budget review of this bill
talked about trapping and you could
Institute trapping it's much more
expensive uh what we try to educate our
operators and the public about is
integrated Pest Management which relies
on things other than just using baiting
which would include exclusion and that
types of things but several these
approaches aren't necessarily that
practical in a farming situation or even
a residential tenant housing those types
of things where you have multiple
families uh so
if we took away Senate second generation
anticoagulants there are other options
available zinc phosphide's one uh
there's a nerve agent that's one the
problem with those chemicals or the
nerve agent is there actually isn't an
antidote
uh for the anticoagulant pesticides
there's uh antidote vitamin K can be
administered for instance if a pet is it
is exposed so there's obviously balances
pluses and minuses to all these options
so
thank you representative datsy uh yes
thank you madam chair
um if these pesticides are so effective
why are we receiving more inquiries
regarding increases in
um pest in rodents
that's a good question if they're so
effective why are we seeing a decline in
in the rodents uh
I don't I don't know I I don't know we
we do see and we do receive an increase
in calls and and I've heard from Health
departments
um people aren't as diligent as they
were in the urban centers as far as
getting the trash moved out
um there was a someone had identified a
actually a fire chief who was also a
public health identified to me that
during covert people home war and you'd
think that they'd be doing more be
diligent to pick up but for some reason
they felt like the trash was increasing
and home so I don't I don't really know
what what the answer is as far as the uh
the increase in rats but there are so
many different traps and and available
um the city of Boston instituted one
it's an electronic trap that electrifies
the you know the road it drops it in the
box and you clean out the box there's a
one that's put into um in the bigger
cities like New York City Chicago they
have um dry ice which you have to cover
up all the holes all the ins and and and
that that works in an urban setting but
but not
um we just I don't I don't know why uh I
was struggling with as many rats and as
we have
uh first representative Potenza and then
a completely foreign subject for I think
for a lot of us so to just try to I may
dump it down to me could you in a in a
nutshell tell me where we're
experiencing the the greatest rat and
mice issues across the state
yeah sure this gets uncomfortable for me
when um about 10 years ago I can tell
you there were coastal towns cities okay
and then we started seeing I got called
I actually had a call from a pesticide
applicator he said he's done with rats
and and that call came from
um more of a rural kind of um 5000
population in a community that was
central New Hampshire
um and and but it lately the last two to
three years it's been pretty much
thank you madam chair and thank you
director for taking my question
there's been a lot of information thrown
out here today regarding this and
just for clarification
s
second generation is not allowed for
Homeowner use is that correct
it's not supposed to be used by
homeowners the problem is they they can
purchase it
thank you thank you madam chair and
um when you say they can purchase it is
that through online means I would say
online in in addition Farm Stores you
know they'll have a five gallon pail
bucket and
um I suppose it could maybe it's a label
violation that's something we could Step
Up um we're not in the you know we don't
go to in the houses you know I mean we
could but we we don't you know typically
we're watching the complaints and the
follow up
thank you and
in listening to the testimony it
is that the first generation written
decides the rodent needs to ingest a lot
more poison into the system before it
um dies and from and maybe I'm not
understanding this correctly but it
would seem that if a raptor or an animal
ate someone something with the first
generation that has a lot more poison in
it it would be much more detrimental
than the second generation I'm just
trying to
uh
discern that yeah and you'll find
studies first generation Second
Generation and noni anticoagulants as
residue in animals but
um as far as
terminating animals in the in the level
again as a commissioner mentioned we
haven't been presented with a clinical
representative Murray thank you madam
chair for taking my question I guess a
little a point of concern I did have was
just in your recent testimony where
you're saying that in in fact
um
non-licensed professionals homeowners
are having access to five gallon buckets
of this stuff in a farm store supply
store how is that happening
uh to the to the quantity in that in a
five gallon quantity is is that
something that your board has oversight
over or how does that get into those
stores for sale sure
um the way this this uh whole topic was
approached and reviewed by EPA in like
2008 and one of their strategies was to
reduce uh private purchase of res of
these second Generations by increasing
the quantity size to make them
non-marketable to Consumers at the
homeowner level
um but it didn't go as far as making
them restricted a restricted pesticide
is something that a certified applicator
can uh have the privilege of purchasing
a homeowner could not do that so as part
of this uh review that EPA is doing now
it would actually make all of these
second generation
anticoagulants restricted regardless of
the container that they were in that
they would be in and they would be
prohibited from uh purchased by uh
non-certified applicators so that that
was kind of a problem
um the uh the fact that they're not
restricted makes them available for
purchase even if you know a homeowner
could purchase large quantities thank
thank you for taking my question so
um
uh this is a kind of a two-part question
one is
um do you know how soon the EPA is
likely to actually act on uh making
these
um restricted use and would it be
possible for us to make them restricted
use at the state level before the EPA
on the first part of the question
I would say no less than six months to a
year on the EPA level the comment period
from the public closes next month
February and then they I'm pretty sure
they have a 90-day required time frame
to review
um so that's three months um so any you
know I my my best guess would be
anywhere from six months to a year at
EPA level could the state move ahead and
restrict
um in that method yeah we the board
could could move ahead and do that um
certainly not without discussion and
um and and and looking the board would
probably look at what the federal
government is is doing and and more than
likely follow the the Federal
approach because if the state goes ahead
and restricts them and it it doesn't
match up with the federal restriction
and then we end up with different
um compliance requirements both federal
and state that that sometimes gets a
representative NAB
you madam chair thank you um I have sort
of a two-part question if that's okay
sure okay
um the commissioner wrote in his letter
there were done decide concern is a
current topic for the board so I wonder
if you could just speak to the board's
path on addressing the rodenticide and
what the timeline for that looks like
notwithstanding what's going on with the
EPA and second to that is what sort of
restrictions does the pesticide control
board normally do and is there a way
that the board itself could think
um sort of holistically about how just
reducing the usage of this so I mean in
one piece would be reducing individuals
using it but other ways should just
reduce the use of these these pesticides
thank you sure does that make sense yeah
well I I think I got it uh the Boyd has
has full Authority
um under the statute to do as they need
uh see fit in as far as restrictions or
prohibition
um I missed the first part I'm so sorry
I um I think it was just like a little
more information on the commissioner's
sentence the Redundant side concern is
the current topic for the board yeah
thank you um so last year the the
governor's office directed the
Department of Agriculture to track
incidents of of residue whether they be
you know um
um the residues that we're seeing right
now or if there were a situation where
an animal was terminated but the
governor's office made it clear that we
would track
but the department would track
incidents of rodenticide and so that was
brought to the board you know the
department received the information from
the governor in turn the department
identified to the board that they need
to um it needs to be a topic and so
that's been going on for at least six
maybe eight months
and as far as the timeline goes I I
don't think there was a timeline put as
far as saying okay you know we've looked
at it for a year and and we're done I I
I don't
there's no there's no timeline as far as
the decision making I think one of the
things that plays into this is these
second generation anticoagans have been
around since the 1970s and so that
that becomes part of the question is
what does it mean to have a residue
we're better at examining things now and
identifying the chemical chemicals we're
finding
um but what does it mean you know and I
think that that that's a big question
and whether or not the board could wrap
that up in a year as far as what they've
how they feel uh uh what their response
representative Bixby
yes it occurs to me that we're talking
about restricted use and we have a
number of new members here this year so
I maybe you could explain what
restricted use means oh thank you um
so in the classification of pesticides
the state of New Hampshire has four
classifications and this is a real
General and the first one is General
General use you might refer to it as
over the counter it's something most
anybody can buy it's a general use type
material so the level of toxicity is
such that it's it's a it's it's
available for use by a homeowner so
that's typically the general use
um then when you bump up either the way
a product is used or its toxicity is
elevated that becomes a restricted use
pesticide and sometimes a manufacturer
can take what would normally be a
general use and make it restricted
because they want it to be used by a
commercial licensed applicator so you
have General use you have restricted use
then you have this group called The
prohibited limited use and those are
real specific uses there's only about a
dozen of them I would say half of them
are for bird control and and the
prohibited limited use the use of them
requires something called a special
permit so it's not just a licensed
individual could use it they would have
to use it under a certain number of
clear specific provisions and then the
last classification is prohibited and
any other questions representative
Potenza
so this this basically goes um kind of a
follow-up to our question when you were
the question that I asked um to the
commissioner was about how you know what
are the numbers of animals that um have
been terminated and we're saying zero at
this point correct
in New Hampshire we have not received a
New Hampshire animal with clinical
information to say clearly that an
animal was terminated due to pesticide
use
so this is this is where to me it would
be how hard it would be that would mean
someone in their backyard that had
that's that sees a dead animal fox or
whatever would have to report it for
then to for it to be tested so we really
don't know those numbers of how many
animals that are deceased from this
correct I mean that's a fear yeah I
would say it's for you can I follow up
yes
um
in regards with purchasing
um so could someone could go on Amazon
or something like that in even though
it's prohibited for
alcohol and all those other types of
things are all controlled like you can't
send I can't go buy somebody a gift
package and send a wine basket to a
certain in it automatically says
prohibited in these states we we can't
have any sort of controls over that
we're for people that are like a
homeowner that's going to be buying
something that's prohibited is that just
really so hard to control like in an
online fashion I know if we're talking
about farm stores and all these other
things you guys I mean there's not that
many people to be able to police this
throughout the state and controlling
businesses is very difficult I can
imagine so
um
yeah um yeah policing the uh the sale
would be difficult
um typically we when we find a homeowner
with a product that they that they
legally shouldn't be using
um it's usually a neighbor complaint I
would say
um but as far as looking at what people
buy and how they're using that product
yeah yeah
Okay so I have a question
if I may maybe this is a question for
fish and game people but so these second
generation anticoagulants have been used
since the 1970s this is what I'm hearing
in testimony
has there been a significant decline in
the Predator population since then or
during this time period
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't be
comfortable putting that number on that
but we we've seen an increase in Birds
of Prey over overall with with eagles if
you if you're talking back to 1970 and
when DDT was uh taken off the shelves in
1972 And we have seen an increase in
that in that that bird of prey but um I
I couldn't speak to uh you know all
populations across the board as far as
whether increasing or decreasing except
the rats yeah yeah
representative come to my you had a
question I did thank you madam chair and
thank you director again for taking my
question
um it seems to me that
um
education I think is the way to go with
um this is there something that the
department is doing on educating the
public regarding rodenticides so when
they're purchasing these products they
understand what effects it can have even
on their pets
when we learned when the department
learned of the the eagle death in
Massachusetts in 2021 directly related
to the second generation anticoagulant
we put up a web page but you know how
web web is you know you're either going
to find it or you're not find it but
it's an educational piece in that
description you can look at it when you
get a chance it identifies other methods
of control
um other than going jump into the it
says right in the in and Bob you're
gonna have to help me out on this one
I'm pretty sure we say in there consider
non-chemical methods or consider you
know trapping before going to chemistry
so that's that's where we are as far as
a little piece of of Education we do
have it on our environmental page which
is um in our division of pesticide
control page and I'm sure it's not the
first thing people would would turn over
as far as when you go on the on the web
but but it is it is there as I mentioned
when we do trainings we always identify
the uh the methods that are non-chemical
um and we do get calls from the public
we got a call
um where uh a husband had ordered a
treatment using the chemical method and
the wife said you get back on that phone
and you tell them we're not we're not
going to do that and and so it became a
contractual problem between the family
and the the company they hired because
they signed into it and then the the the
wife said we're going to go with
trapping and and not chemicals so that's
another piece of um opportunity we have
to say okay that's a that's a that's a
method you know that's a lot of
integrated Pest Management
representative come to our follow-up
yes Madam chair thank you and again
thank you director
um I was just noticing that you had said
that there are
um antidotes
um for the second generation
anticoagulants however for some of the
non-anticoagulants there are no
antidotes is that in regards to poison
control in humans or animals
so on on the pesticide labels there's
usually typically notes to veterinarians
where they're dealing with a homeowner
pet that might have been exposed to a
rodenticide and
um if you see information on a
anticoagulant label it'll talk about
administering vitamin K as a as an
antidote when you're talking about the
the nerve agents that are not
anticoagulants there really is no
antidote and so
it's basically a wait and watch and see
and hope that hope for the best uh with
some of these other approaches
the rodenticide control thank you
any other questions from the committee
no seeing none
thank you so much for your testimony
today we appreciate all your information
I'd like to call Representative will
Darby
mm-hmm
thank you madam thank you madam chair
thank you members of the committee for
letting me testify
um I'd like to relate an abbreviated
incident
um my family experience that is a result
of second generation any coagulant
rodenticides such as those prohibited by
this bill
which led me to co-sponsoring this boom
my family lives in Nashua with
neighboring houses on all sides and a
fully fenced in yard
we like to let our dogs out in the
backyard and they enjoy the interaction
with other dogs beyond the fence
several years ago our dog Casper
about 20 pounds was out as normal before
bed
in the middle of the night he awoke and
was sick in the corner of the room
when my wife checked on him
she observed a small mostly intact
rodent in the vomit
which she disposed of while cleaning up
the mess
we did not think much of the event but
when we awoke in the morning Casper was
lethargic we monitor them throughout the
day and noticed he stopped eating and
slept the entire day
the following day we brought him to the
vet and we were and we're told that he
probably had a stomach issue and he was
put on a special diet
he continued to refuse food even when
hand fed so my wife asked that I work
from home the following day
to continue checking on his progress
at some point well while I was
attempting to feed him I noticed his
gums were bleeding
calling the vet again they indicated it
was critical that he'd be seen
immediately
with this additional symptom they
conducted more blood tests
these determined that he had consumed
rodents rodenticide and required a
vitamin K infusion
we were besides ourselves
not using Rhode Island sides at home we
wondered how we would come into contact
until my wife recalled the regurgitated
mouse from a few nights earlier
Casper had to stay in the veterinary
hospital for two days and be kept on
vitamin K for two additional weeks
we were relieved that our dear boy was
saved
even if we were out fifteen hundred
dollars
an expense and an incident that could
have been avoided if our neighbors had
selected an alternative solution to
their managing their pest problem that
was less toxic to non-target species
even in Nashua we have Hawks and owls
visit semi-regularly
if our dog surrounded by a fenced in
yard can ingest a poisoned Mouse and
nearly die
these birds of prey are much more prone
to such recklessness
I urge you to vote ought to pass on this
Bill thank you
and I'm happy to take questions
any questions from the committee
representative Murray
thank you madam chair for taking my
question thank you representative um
it sounds to me based on your testimony
that time was of the essence as to when
the vitamin K got administered based on
your recount of the veterinarian
urging you to bring the pet in
imminently that's that's what they
relate to us that we had that he had to
come in immediately
um and which is which is what we did yes
follow-up if I may sure and are you
aware of there being a a sort of and
maybe this is a question for somebody
else but
um what is the time frame in which post
ingesting it an animal does have to seek
treatment is that within hours within a
day two days all I can tell I mean I've
read right that that demise may live
several days but I I can't I'm not a
better uh veterinarian
thank you
representative thank you madam chair and
um when you're done could I have your
testimony please I I did mail it as well
okay thank you but I can give you this
copy if you'd like
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
representative Darby
I'd like to call uh Rob Johnson from New
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for the record I'm Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau is the federation's policy
director
we don't disagree with the importance of
rodents that have to the food chain for
wildlife No Doubt
and as I think you any of you have
reviewed the bill you're aware that it
it provides exemptions for agriculture
but as we previously said we are very
much opposed to the bill
there's an established process for this
type of discussion and decision making
in place
in your wisdom the legislature before
you back in the mid 80s New Hampshire
was one of the early states to establish
a a review board a pesticide review
board delegated with a responsibility of
regulating pesticides in the state
it has the has the expertise and and I I
don't know of if director Russo has
provided with the rsas but the the RSA
establishing the makeup of the board is
RSA 430 colon 30.
and then 430 colon 31 uh is the
responsibilities and authority of the
board
and I I can speak Farm Bureau we can
speak to the the process we've had an
issue with our Growers with relative to
sweet corn in the state and bird damage
it's in it's been our some of our growth
had quite a Time particularly in the
southern part of the state there's a
there's a product on the market it's
called avatrol that some of our Growers
are aware of and it's it's it can be
used around uh for bird control around
buildings but there it but the label
restricts it to that it's not allowed
for use in the field and we have Growers
that would like to use it because of it
is effective
what we did we went to the pesticide
control board
and brought the issue to them
this was if I've got my year right this
is before the pandemic uh 20 2019 so we
started this process
and we still don't have use of it
and uh initially there was a there was a
meeting we had which involved
Cooperative Extension we invited fish
and game we invited a whole group of
stakeholders to discuss it so just
because we wanted to know where were the
concerns what could be done what was the
process and all so we had that initial
meeting then we went to the pesticide
control board
they they and again if you'll see the
makeup of the boy there's there's
expertise there from from various state
agency Fish and Game Des HHS
Department of Agriculture licensed
applicator
and they wanted to see some data
rightfully so they wanted some data so
we applied for some funding through the
the IPM fund within the Department of
Agriculture with some of the the
pesticide fees go towards and we we
approached the USDA their uh Wildlife
Management folks who can use Avatar
legally and and we we set up a couple of
of uh study points on farms in the state
and then we went we there was report
that we provided to the pesticide
control board
we all recognized based on it we that we
needed more data we went back and we're
in the process of conducting we've now
completed we need to submit the report
but a second study so what I'm my point
in raising this is that that it's
thorough and and despite this this
whether we're our Growers are going to
have to get the use of it that they want
we don't know my guess is they'll look
at the information and then they'll
I mean the the idea of a working group
is is fine but let the pesticide con
control board convene that work and
would do it through them they do it
anyway
um
as as far as as prior to our request for
avatrol the question was asked of you
know have there been other requests
other ideas or other things that could
be done our Growers have to demonstrate
all the things that they have been doing
throughout the process
um
I'm sorry man I'm just trying to skip
again if I uh the the the board they
they meet quarterly but they can meet
more often as needed they bring in they
bring in the expertise they don't have
they're very thorough
and I guess I'll close with a couple
things I guess I want to answer a uh a
question that was is regarding and I
don't know if the it was exactly meant
this but what would the impact of
passing this bill and for those of you
that have been in the legislature a few
few years you've heard me say this
before when similar bills will come up
do you as a legislature really want to
be uh taking up every single uh request
to ban or allow a pesticide that's going
to come your way once you stop down that
road
you you and it's all due respect to you
you don't have the expertise you have
established a board that does that works
well
into just to give you an idea of another
area where that I think is pertinent to
this is uh hold uh for many years you as
the legislature again many years ago uh
you regulated hunting seasons up until
the mid 1980s believe it or not and it
was finally realized when we had some
real issues with a wildlife population
it was it was a geez we've got this
agency fishing game with experts these
biologists that that should be doing
this in the legislature in its wisdom at
the time uh provided them the authority
to set seasons and they have been
sentenced and they have public hearings
and they take import and such and such
so again I would I would urge you uh to
to itl this bill and knowing that you
have a process in place that will will
deal with the issue and I think deal
with it relatively well and I'll leave
it at that Madam chair thank you thank
you any questions from the committee
seeing none
and you indicated three minutes uh yes
ma'am I'm gonna try and stick to it uh
feel free to hit me with any questions
related to decide this is my life I am a
wildlife rehabilitator and when someone
finds an animal that was poisoned they
do not call uh your pesticide people
they don't call their doctor if it's
their pet they call their veterinarian
if it's a wild hawk or a wild fox or any
other Predator they call me
it is not an emotional thing I come here
to you with it is science based that's
why I can answer a lot of questions some
people who sell this stuff can't answer
as far as the amount of poison an animal
has to eat for it to bleed out
internally they can't tell you because
even when we test these animals livers
uh for what was it called uh I think he
something like a trace it's not Trace
okay
have you ever been to your doctor and
had your kid tested for lead did they
tell you you had like a little bit of
lead
kid just got a little bit of lettuce got
a little bit of poison when they test
those animals for poison what they do is
they take a sample of the animal's liver
and they test them and what I can tell
you is it's very rare for a bird of prey
or a predator species to come back
testing positive for just one form of
rodenticide poisoning they usually test
positive for at least three
there's no way on Earth you guys haven't
had animals of prey dying from rat
poison
there's no way
I can show you multiple tests I'm just
over the Border in Massachusetts asked
by many of your constituents to come
today because I own a wildlife rescue
that's followed by over a hundred
thousand people and this mattered a lot
to a lot of people because I posted by a
lot of the animals that I've taken care
of
um
it can be denied some people will say oh
you have an ambulance so it's standard
procedure now if you're taking care of a
predatory species and you're a wildlife
rehabilitator to draw that animal's
blood
rat poison works by
depleting the body of vitamin K your
body has like 50 things that have to
happen in order for your blood to clot
if one of those things is removed your
blood can't clot clotting is the very
beginning process to Healing you can't
clot you can't heal that doesn't mean
that you okay you're fine unless you get
cut your body is healing itself right
now in this room you bump into something
anything your body is constantly healing
itself
the body becomes completely depleted of
vitamin K
I do mainly mammals
California's starting a link between
boxes with mange and
um and poison because the poison
compromises the immune system makes
these animals more prone to these things
a lot of foxes with mange that I get
four out of five their blood is not clot
normally your average mammal's blood
should clot in two to five minutes your
average bird of preys five to seven
we're talking about animals that can't
claw for 20 30 minutes I can tell you
that your average Fox bleeds out
abdominally your average Board of prey
bleeds out peripherally
I can tell you this because I've seen so
many of them I can tell you this because
I work with people who see these animals
all the time and I can show you video
after video of blood we take from these
yes the amount of poison meant to kill
one rat is not going to kill a fox it's
not going to kill an owl your average
great horned owl eats 2 000 rodents
every year
your pesticide people thought that your
bird's a prey species are increasing
they're not you can Google it birds of
prayer down significantly globally
your rodent population is increasing how
if they're using the most effective
methods you want to know why because of
a bird of prey eats six or seven
poisoned rats and it dies
that bird would have eaten two thousand
that year now it's dead Mother Nature
has her way of taking care of these
I this is an emotional thing for me and
I I'm very scientific about a lot of
these things I have stood by these
necropsies because pesticide companies
will tell you just because the animal
tested positive its liver doesn't mean
it necessarily died from rat poison so
I've had to sit by necropsies that prove
significant internal hemorrhaging of
these animals
which basically means they've bled out
internally
four-month-old Fox
four months old positive for three
different types of rat poison bled out
internally I took its blood which should
have clotted within two to five minutes
I went to the veterinarian's office four
hours later after it died which was
awful to witness by the way that is no
easy death
is blood never clotted
never clotted this animal would have
helped
if I were a construction worker and I
built you a house that lasted a year I'd
go to jail
if a pesticide company is coming to your
house and giving you stuff it's going to
kill the six rats in your house it's
going to kill your neighborhood fox or
your neighborhood owl
your problem's going to come back it's
kind of going to come back way worse
and your pesticide people need to be
talking to your Wildlife rehabilitators
those are volunteers in your community
that see this firsthand those are the
people who are seeing these animals that
are being affected by this and
absolutely you can see test after test
Tufts Wildlife Clinic was studying Birds
of Prey they tested every bird that came
in hit by car whatever
the first few years they tested
I think 70 of them were positive for rat
poison this last year they tested every
single bird of prey tested positive for
rat poison and I can tell you even if it
isn't enough to kill them certainly have
any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee yes representative
so these have been around from the 1970s
is there any explanation given for why
this problem seems so maybe it's always
been here and it's just now getting
attention or is there a sense that the
problem is increasing I think the
problem is increasing
um Wildlife rehabilitators are newer and
so there haven't been a lot of tests
like in order to prove it you'd have to
test the animal's liver
um and in animals that don't die from it
that we're treating as someone was
asking about how long do you need to
give vitamin K for
um
uh I don't know how it's taken this long
but I know that California uh has proved
that it's affected the the mammals and
the birds of prey in Massachusetts is
also trying to pass the bill right now
um the the vitamin K thing I want to
mention is uh it depends on how many
animals how bad
the poison is in the animal
in the animals that we take care of uh
it's six weeks of treatment
and I also sorry this thing so many
things I want to say
um when I when we do knee crops to these
animals I don't know if you've ever seen
rat poison a lot of it's like lime green
their livers are lime green they're
supposed to be a dark red
um it's their kidneys it's awful and I
would love to show anyone who works for
a pesticide company pictures and
documentation of all these things
sorry
representative germanna thank you madam
chair and thank you very much for your
testimony
um sorry would you support the creation
we've had the uh the Audubon uh New
Hampshire Audubon recommend the creation
of working group which would include
licensed New Hampshire wildlife
rehabilitators would you support the
creation of a group like that because
you know one of the things we certainly
need to do is to be able to accurately
quantify the the problems so absolutely
supportive working group like that there
must be a disconnect for for this the
information that I've heard
um there has to be disconnected I think
we have to get these people talking to
each other absolutely
thank you
sorry oh my gosh I just went I'm sorry
go ahead
um so when in when uh when a rat or a
mouse ingests
um any of these
second generation
I mean if it's the black box right and
the mouse goes in and takes a piece
I thought what happens is they have to
go find water correct isn't that what
has to happen they die rat go try to
find water after they eat that they can
digest it from where it is and it's not
just rats and mice to get into it it's
Chipmunks that you gourd themselves and
you can see the actual hemorrhaging in
their cheeks when you find check monk
that's had it and they can tell you how
much it takes to kill one rat that
doesn't stop a rat from gorging because
it takes a while to go through the GI
tract which takes you know after it's
digested then it can start making their
blood have difficulty clotting but they
may have ingested far more than they
needed to to die
um and they're just running around and
they're running and the thing is
compromise pray predator species are
taught to look for compromised prey and
when an animal's slowly Bleeding Out
believe me that rat's gonna walk a lot
slower than another rat that's healthy
so that's how they're able to pick these
guys up they're they're going after them
because they're walking slower and
they're compromise they're slowly
bleeding out obviously I I highly
suggest uh snap traps I'm not opposed to
killing rats I understand that they
cause a huge health risk
um and and we've suggested to people use
snap traps take that dead rat or dead
mouse and throw it in the back of your
yard let all the predator species know
here's the place to go to to dine you
yes so uh we heard from the Department
that they had not had reports of uh
animal of animals that had
um
have been shown to have died from uh
from ingestion and I'm wondering if you
uh if you submit rep when you run across
these animals do you submit reports to
government agencies uh as a matter of
course to make sure it's documented
there's no testing right now it's
something we're trying to work with our
state on too there's there's no way of
tracking this now I do have tests and I
know there's no way that the rehabbers
in this state don't have tests too
um it can be argued he said that they
tested a lot of animals that were hunted
that tested positive for rat poison but
without a veterinarian doing a necropsy
and confirming that there was actual
hemorrhaging it can be argued the animal
didn't die from it but there's no
arguing that it was exposed the problem
is also financially cost me four hundred
dollars to have a fox and we don't get
paid to do this uh 400 have a fox knee
crop seat and test it it was that four
month old Fox and it broke my heart and
I didn't care I spent the money because
people will argue that's not what it was
and defend actively after the vet opened
that animal up and tested the liver it
could not be argued that's four hundred
dollars one fox and we're all volunteers
for the State uh I think it would be
good if all the states made more efforts
to do things like that and again like I
said if we're using rat poison and the
rat population is getting worse it
stands to reason that we're killing the
birds of prey who are actually helping
us
could I have a follow-up
um
would it um
if there are I I recognize you're in
Massachusetts and that you know we're
dealing with the New Hampshire law here
but I'm you you have colleagues in New
Hampshire that uh I'm wondering if there
were if it would make sense to have some
sort of a standard reporting procedure
for when repel
rehabilitators get animals in that are
showing signs or you know or showing
clear evidence of poisoning I think
another difficult thing too is some of
them we can save like they were
mentioning Vitamin K is one way that we
can save them and when you've had an
animal that you're sure has rat poison
because it's bleeding out and you give
vitamin K and it survives I can't then
test its liver and prove it what I can
tell you is the vitamin K meds blood
clot normal again so it stands to reason
but one could argue the only ones that
we could actually prove it with there
are the ones that die
um but yes if if the state worked with
Wildlife rehabilitators more that would
be helpful uh I know Wildlife we're here
with rehabilitators were asked to come
here and nobody wanted to stand front of
everybody and talk about it which makes
it difficult but I think that um I
certainly anytime someone wants to come
to you know I understand that I'm I'm
right across the border I'm in
Massachusetts but we're difficult and
all those things that are listed are the
things that all the owls and the foxes
are testing positive for they affect
mammals
whether you're in New Hampshire or
Massachusetts or the other side of the
world the same way a follow-up
so uh is it uh is it possible to get can
you can you uh detect the poisoning from
a blood sample or do you need in order
to confirm it you need to have a liver
sample you would need to confirm that it
was poison you would need a liver sample
you can confirm that the blood isn't
clotting properly but you can't confirm
why if it's poison it all uh stays in
the liver okay thank you you're welcome
excuse me if you'd like to testify later
thank you um I I do have a question I'd
like to I'm interested to know you as a
wildlife rehabber how many
Predator animals do you see say in a
month's time
that have this issue
it's mainly the adults that I see that
would have this issue it's probably more
in the winter because in the spring we
have the babies I received six foxes
this year four of which
were
so one I was able to save so I can't
confirm I can tell you that vitamin K
made its blood clot normally again but I
can't tell you scientifically without a
sample of his liver but three of them uh
were positive for rat poison and I can
tell you that
um
the we work with uh call
Cape Ann wildlife and I have all of
theirs that we probably have 11 positive
um owls
for rat poison uh the same poisons that
were in that the S they're all asgars
um
we don't those 11 is that in a year yes
okay probably more to be honest with you
some of them they were able to save so I
can't prove definitively to you
um but I I can certainly send the board
all all those positive tests
uh consistent with and the findings
consistent with these animals Blood Out
uh their bodies just one big bruise with
birds their bodies one big bruise it's
easy to tell you just put the feathers
aside and it's just black and blue with
uh with a fox or a mammal it's more
abdominal hemorrhaging so you can't look
at them as much they need to be more cut
open to see thank you any other
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony this afternoon thank you I'd
sorry about that Madam chair and the
members of the committee my name is Adam
Karachi and I'm a second generation
owner of my family business pestend
which is located in Plaistow New
Hampshire we currently service most of
New England including New Hampshire for
general pest control wildlife and of
course rodents we've been in business
since 1977 and currently have 85
employees and I'm here today to explain
why we are against HB 326
rodents are something that people do not
want to think about especially when it
comes to the health and safety of their
family unfortunately it is a fact of
life that rodents pose major concerns to
our food supply well I'm not ha well I'm
happy to see that there is some
acknowledgment to this due to the
exceptions list the problem does not
stop at those type of locations
the problem is that these look uh I'm
sorry the problem is the locations that
are not included on the exceptions list
a major concern is the expense that
comes along with the Banning of the
second generation anticoagulant
rodenticides landlords and small
business owners especially restaurant
owners are already feeling the pain of
the finances in our current economic
climate restaurant owners are finally
starting to recover from coveted
shutdowns and then got hit with major
inflation costs if this bill is to pass
you're going to take a service that
maybe is 100 a month for them and turn
it into 100 a week because we're going
to have to go back to check those snap
traps and check everything on a more
frequent basis this is going to lead to
them trying to do it on their own and I
know as David Rousseau was talking about
we want to try and restrict these
as you all know if you want to find
something you will find it you can get
what you want whether it's on the
internet going across state lines
ordering it from wherever you want to to
be able to do it on your own
that's when they're not going to follow
the labels that's when there will be
label violations and that's when bigger
issues will come about
the bigger impact to me
representative Cannon brought up that
New Hampshire is a tourist playground I
completely agree with that between
skiing and lakes and beaches and leaf
peeping
people come to New Hampshire because it
is a great place to vacation and to
travel to
what we don't want to have happen is the
negative press that Massachusetts New
York are already seeing due to rodent
populations
one bad review because they were at a
hotel or a restaurant and a mouse ran
across can an area
we've seen it happen before I know of
restaurants myself that have been shut
down and gone out of business because
rodents ran by while someone was eating
I can tell you from a personal
experience that I've had we service a
local butcher shop
they have been dealing with mice
for five to seven years
there's generations of mice that are
living within the store
they don't have
these mice don't leave
that store
we've pulled out in the last year 250
rodents from this store
we're using just about every tactic that
we can
snap traps are not always the best
option
in a mouse and rat colony especially a
rat colony there's an alpha male
what I can tell you about an alpha male
it's lived for a long time it's very
smart there's videos of alpha male rats
taking their tail and hitting a snap
trap to set it off so it can go and get
the bait
it will not get caught in these traps
representative Cannon mentioned that she
even had
traps within her home
and this is something that we need to be
very aware of we need you can't remove a
tool from our toolbox Banning something
you're never going to get it back and
while we've continued to have
this growth in the rodent population
yes there's a lot of reasons for that
covid was a huge one we had all of these
rodents that were used to feeding at
their typical sites such as a restaurant
now I had to find out find food
elsewhere that's why they're starting to
end up at homes and in places where we
haven't seen them before
a mouse can fit into a hole the size of
a dime
so exclusion work sure it can be done
nothing is perfect
also with exclusion Mark you go from a
300 job to a three thousand dollar job
when we're talking about these food
plants and the stuff that or the places
that are on the exceptions list they
have the resources and the funds to pay
for these extra services
when you're talking about low income
they can't pay three thousand dollars
for that
so are they supposed to live with
rodents are they supposed to have mice
running around their their home
no so instead they're gonna go and buy
it on their own and again now we get two
professionals not being involved and
the last one I have is we had a house
where there was an elderly couple
they had no kids
their house was infested with rats
they only the only reason that got
brought to our attention was the
neighbors were complaining because the
rats were running all around the yard
and we finally got in there
they had over 150 rats that we pulled
out from this house that these people
were living with
the respiratory issues were unbelievable
they had major health side effects due
to the rats that were inside of this
house
we started with snap traps and we got
the majority of them with snap traps but
yeah at the end we had to use bait to
finish them off
the single feeding is what can make the
difference because if you have a rodent
population going back to that butcher
shop the rodents there loved feeding on
the the meat and the delicious food
that's there
so they might go and feed on the bait
once and then not touch it for weeks
because they have other food sources
well that doesn't help if you're talking
about first generation
that's where the second generation comes
in because you want to knock this
population out
so in closing I in no way shape or form
think that there isn't a concern there's
obviously a concern and that has been
talked about Nationwide and there's a
lot of people looking at it they've
brought up the EPA is even dealing with
it
but we need to make decisions based off
of facts and Science and not off of what
we think might be happening
any questions from the committee
representative Murray thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um
I guess this just occurred to me in the
sense that I do know that the department
has come before our committee and talked
significantly before about IPM programs
and training requirements licensure
requirements and because this is a
non-restricted
chemical
does that mean that somebody like
yourself is not necessarily tested on
the application of that no so it's it's
different with us because we're
commercial for hire so if you're
commercial for hire you do have to be
licensed
um so everyone in in our company and
should be in every company has licensing
continuing continuing education courses
and credits that they have to have
license renewals
um so there is testing that you
initially have to take and then those
courses to to keep up your credits thank
you
representative Bixby so it was mentioned
that um the escars are not currently uh
restricted use pesticides do you think
that making them restricted use
pesticides might reduce the amount of
um uh uh off well off label use that
might be happening from uh from non-red
from non-licensed people
I do as much as I don't like further
regulation if I'm being brutally honest
I think the biggest problem here is a
lot of consumer use as opposed to
professional use the typically when when
we see things we walk into a house and a
homeowner has found something we've seen
just plates of bait put out that's not a
professional putting that out um from
what I've seen so I do think it would
help
follow up yes good yeah and what's what
sort of procedures do you use to or is
there a procedure you can use in order
to
um reduce the likelihood that the
animals that are that receive the bait
are then uh out in the environment where
they can be eaten by owls and foxes and
Etc so again we follow the label so our
placement of our our traps our bait
stations which are tamper resistant
they're locked so they do go through a
process to make sure just no one can go
and open them once the rodents feed off
of the bait they tend to feel sick
because again they're bleeding out
that's what's happening they don't go
for water to enter a previous statement
that was said mice don't even need water
they get it from their food but
typically they go back to their nesting
they don't feel good when you don't feel
good where do you go back to your bed
um so what we've seen is that's what
typically is happening but to say that
you know it's a wild animal there's no
way for me to tell it don't go into the
yard you have to go over this way
okay thank you you're welcome
representative germanna thank you madam
chair thank you for your your testimony
today uh so I'll ask you the same
question I asked uh our Wildlife
rehabilitator uh uh witness uh would you
be supportive of the type of working
group that the uh that New Hampshire
Audubon has uh proposed which would
include not only a wildlife
rehabilitator but also licensed
pesticide applicators I wouldn't be
against it again I do believe that the
pesticide board does have a process
already in place
um and I I've been a part of
subcommittees where they do bring in
other people
um so I'm not opposed to it but I would
leave that up to the pesticide board and
what they believe is the best option
thank you
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony today thank you
I'd like to call up next uh Gary Menon
senior
thank you committee members for having
me inviting me this opportunity to speak
on behalf of
uh New Hampshire house bill 326 which I
fully support
um my name is Gary Menace senior I am a
resident of Sterling Massachusetts and
I'm a long time promoter of raptor
protection
and an advocate for a like-minded
organization known as Raptors are the
solution.org and I'm an ambassador for
an organization known as talking birds
which is a radio show and you can hear
every weekend which
promotes the appreciation of our Birds
in this current age of increasing
species extension extinctions every
effort is required to minimize the basic
survival challenges of Wildlife
especially our magnificent Raptors the
Hawks Falcons owls and Eagles
these birds face any number of human
initiated existential threats every day
the habitat loss Firearms Nets fish line
discards power line and wind turbine
accidents
a vehicular traffic and most avoidably
via the use of rodenticides
rodents such as mice and rats are a
staple for these Raptors and when a
rodent after feeding from a poison bait
trap makes its way back outside for
water and I do disagree with the
previous statement they do look for
water because they're bleeding out and
they need rehydration
um they make its way out for water they
fall prey to a hawk or an owl and in
turn this poison uh these highly
beneficial predators
it should be noted in this regard that
over half of raptor species worldwide
are currently in Decline
in a Tufts University study of
red-tailed Hawks barn owls eastern
screech owls great horned owls these are
carcasses by the way they're not live
birds that have been admitted to the
Tufts Wildlife Clinic over the past
decade and before well over 80 percent
tested positive for anti-coagulant
rodenticides this is well over a hundred
Birds
we're not talking single numbers here
numerous other studies in States across
the country
have seen similar if not worse
unconscionable effects on numerous
Raptor species and it's no small point
that these birds die a horrifically
cruel death
indeed it's getting worse all great
horned owls all red tail hawks are
preeminent natural
rodent controllers 100 of them tested by
Tufts over the past two years have
tested positive for anti-second
Generation anticoagulant rodenticides
I'll get caused poisoned by those were
initial sites
that this is happening in New Hampshire
as well has been documented by wings of
the Dawn wings of Don the dawn Wildlife
rehabit Rehabilitation Center in haniker
as recently as this past October
Raptors however are not the only animals
harmed by these rodenticides as foxes
make Bobcats Fishers pets and even
humans are often poisoned by these
toxins the fact that these other animals
are being poisoned in New Hampshire was
reflected in the recent September
October edition of New Hampshire's
Wildlife Journal regarding people a
survey by the EPA found that at least 25
000 children under the under the age of
six ingested enough rodenticides to
suffer poisoning symptoms in past years
and currently about 15 000 calls per
year come into the CDC from parents
whose children have eaten rodenticides
indeed if even if one places bait where
children can't get into it rodents are
after distribute it around one's house
and property there's really no set no
such thing as a
as a
as a bait trap that cannot be violated
rodents by their nature they're required
to chew they will chew through these Bay
traps they will distribute the food
elsewhere
the most variant of these poisons are
the escars that is the second generation
anticoagulant rodenticides which are
listed in House Bill 326. these
particular rodenticides are the ones
showing up in the vast majorities of
raptor necropsies and in the viscer of
all four four bald eagles which were
poisoned to death in Massachusetts in
2021.
the ecosystem the ecosystem Services
provided by native Wildlife predators
are a public trust as was mentioned
before just like clean air and water and
as we and we as New England residents
are obligated to conserve these Wildlife
populations
as predators of small mammals they play
an important role in controlling the
population of rodents throughout the
regions to improve overhaul Health and
Welfare rodents will never be eliminated
we've known this since I think 1542 or
thereabouts with a bubonic plague
oh can only control them many residents
and other visitors take much pleasure in
the viewing of these birds and in so
doing contribute to the economy should
it should no further Raptor casualties
occur do the element due to the
elimination of rodenticides from their
environment via adoption of more
stringent controls on escars the
likelihood of their survival for
generations to come to cherish and enjoy
as far better guaranteed
there are far safer and equally
effective ways to combat rodents from
house cats to ultrasonic repellers to
carbon dioxide pellets pellets to fully
automated traps and self-contained that
are self-contained and self-clear every
after every instantaneous kill among
many others but the most important thing
people can do is eliminate their food
source if you have rats infestation they
are getting food from somewhere you need
to keep that food from them by putting
it into road and proof containers taking
care of your garbage your trash is the
most important thing dumpsters for
example
um
well that's why I'm here today voicing
my support of New Hampshire house bill
326 as if passed it will go a long way
towards ensuring that our children
grandchildren and Beyond will still be
able to experience the beauty power and
Grace of these magnificent magnificent
birds and mammals thank you
thank you for your testimony and
I actually have a question
um I have chickens
and I have put chicken feed out for them
to eat which
can attract rats rodents and I've had in
the past problems with rats and rodents
coming into my chicken coop and having a
good time eating whatever
so how do you how do you suggest
eliminating that food supply because if
I did that my chickens wouldn't be able
to have access to food
I I guess you could maybe control
whether where their food stuff is being
made available to them to eat it but I
also would suggest that you could apply
certain automatic trap measure
measurements measures outside of the
chicken coop where the rats may be
entering there there's one trap called
the uh the good nature Auto traps a20
model 824 and it's self-bait self sets
and self-clears and you could place this
Outside The Coop and hopefully the rats
might find that that bait more more
desirable than what's in the chicken
coops that's one suggestion
um
I'm not sure of other other ones just I
guess I could look into that but
thank you well you know the the other
thing is that rats are very neophobic
which means that they don't they don't
like to do anything new
and to put any kind of
apparatus like that it doesn't seem like
that would be as attractive to them as
as going to say what you're saying is
very true I mean even people with bird
feeders I mean bird feeder in the yard
and of course of course the birds
scatter the food from the feeder falls
to the ground it will attract rodeness
there's no question about that yeah I'm
not sure what the answer is okay well
thank you I appreciate your your
testimony today anybody else have
questions
thank you
I'd like to call Daniel Brady
thank you madam chair and uh mcminnie my
name is Daniel Brady I'm the co-owner
with my brother of Anchor Pest Services
we're located in Manchester New
Hampshire but we service from the Lakes
Region down to the Seacoast over to
Peterborough and
um the border so most most of the
population of the state
um I'll try to avoid some of the topics
just because we're not repeating them Ad
nauseam but
um our main clientele is residential we
don't we stay away from the food
factories we stay away from these we
focus them only mainly on the home our
charge as a pest control operator
licensed by the state is to protect the
health and wellness of the individual
and the environment we take that
seriously
we have weekly training where we review
best practices as well as label and
compliance we we have regular spot
checks on the technicians out in the
field to make sure that they're applying
we have quality control checks at random
with our clients to make sure that the
the stations are up up kept and in good
placement obviously it does take a
measure of IPM where you're controlling
the environment with non-pesticide
application methods we for instance if
you're on there and you notice that
there's a bird of prey Nest we don't
apply pesticides there or especially
rodenticides you you move it to other
locations because frankly they're
already doing to her point they're
already doing some of the control for us
so we do work in tandem with with
environmental factors that being said
though
some factors are not controllable a
single pair of rats can have over 1250
descendants in a year that's that's not
sustainable with snaps
um we have implemented and deployed the
good nature the a24 traps and they're
really cool not super effective
um because it
it has to be constantly reset you only
get 99 shots out of a cartridge before
it has to be replaced the bait may not
be palatable to them in whatever you
choose there's just a lot of
barriers and if you use those types of
products then it's if it doesn't work
you're out of luck same thing with the
snap traps we've employed those because
people like when we can take the problem
with us
um the problem is is just their rapid
reproductive rates and some of the other
issues that we've found especially with
exclusion work is preferred I'd rather
prevent a problem than try to solve a
problem absolutely and our clients would
we do that as well
what we found this morning I was
speaking to our technicians during our
regular weekly training meeting
and I asked hey how many of you have
crawled under a mobile home or
manufactured home this past month
um all of them had raised their hand and
all of them reported rats we have in
since October
um of just rat and mouse so rodent only
new calls we've had 131 new calls for
rodents only not including our general
calls that we're getting in addition of
those 27 have been in the higher popular
downtown of Manchester in the high
density housing you're going to get 11
of them in Nashua in the same population
centers and then spread out throughout
Seabrook Dover Rochester each of those
about five or six a piece and then
sporadically throughout the rest of the
state and that is just since October
that we've had like I said that over 131
calls in addition and those are just the
ones we track that are specifically for
rodents not the general pest control
control calls that include our rodent
treatments so it is a prolific problem
throughout the state and
if we and again as I go back to those
trailer homes or mobile homes or
manufactured homes
rats will chew through the floor they'll
chew through the wall we've seen it you
cannot exclude that it's physically
impossible to prevent that through other
methods you have to kill the rats and so
yes we can trap it
but it's prohibitively expensive they
cannot afford more often than not the
additional
visits that it would require to set that
many especially when you consider like I
said up to 1200 per food and
environmental factors up to 1200
descendants per pair that it's just a
hurricane
task to try to overcome that with just
snaps alone and especially the
underserved and our lower income
clientele they just wouldn't be able to
afford the required trip visits so for
that and because there is a responsible
use there is a methodology and practice
in place that we support and we do
adhere to the the department of AGS and
Department of pesticides um
rules and regulations and Licensing we
definitely oppose this bill and support
the existing organization as it is
thank you for your testimony any
questions representative germanna thank
you madam chair and thank you for your
testimony uh so I I think it's clear
though one of the things that that we're
going to need is more accurate
information right to tell us something
about the extent to which these escars
are ending up in predators and their
lethality for for Predators but my
question for you is do we at least in
some applications do we end up putting
ourselves uh kind of behind the eight
ball in in the sense that if we are
doing damage to the Predator population
right if we think about the the pest
control that is done Naturally by uh
Predators like Raptors right uh at some
level are we making the problem worse
because there is this question about why
we're seeing a proliferation of of
rodents if we now have uh and have for
quite some time had these pesticides
which are are so effective so isn't
there at least in some applications the
danger of doing damn image to Natural
Predators who would be taking out a
considerable number of of those rodents
if they were not affected by the
pesticides
well yes you could technically have that
as an issue but I mean as Adam was
mentioning a house mouse for instance
they don't leave a house a lot of our
clients we do a lot of multiple
occupancy dwelling in downtown
Manchester
that that's not an issue that's not the
problem but that you can't seal
especially with like fire codes and all
this other stuff there's so many other
limiting factors that our rodenticides
aren't even placed outside of the
property but if they are responsibly
used at or responsibly used and placed
it's
if it is a factor in the decline of of
Predator animals it's
very far down the list of factors I mean
I would say the fact that we're just
building houses in their environment is
driving more of them away and driving
them just environment loss is going to
be more of a factor than rodenticide use
um so
I don't think that it's enough to factor
in especially when weighed against sorry
for taking too long but especially when
weighed against the diseases and the the
problems that come from rats
specifically
um I mean you see it in other states
that have the bands in a sense this and
they're seeing increase especially in
population centers of
these rodent instances but also the
disease diseases that they transmit
which is again the primary function we
don't want to just kill stuff for
killing's sake the point is to protect
the people the residents of New
Hampshire that's who we focus on
can I ask a quick follow-up sure sure
thank you uh and so would you be in
favor of you've asked this so you should
know it's coming right of of a working
group because it seems to me that not
only do we need the data but there are
also questions about what applications
we have a list of exceptions here
perhaps that list is not comprehensive
enough but would you be in favor of a
working group that would be designed to
aggregate this data and to talk about
appropriate applications uh I mean who's
ever going to be against more
information and more knowledge for that
we do have a wonderful board that is
very robust and involved and they're
easy to get a hold of they're easy to
answer questions and so if you want to
add to that if it's not undue burden I
don't see an issue with that as long as
it then follows the existing enforcement
and Rule regulating process but I don't
see an issue with more information ever
being a problem thank you thank you
so the population just to clarify
population of residents here not the
rodent population are kind of both
um yeah so the population of uh people
moving uh right we've had a growth in
our population of people into the state
and I live in a rural area and notice
that there's a lot more building going
on uh which concerns me how the wildlife
is going to their normal track tracks
through the woods they're going to have
to divert and everything else so with
the increase of population uh would that
help contribute to the rodent growth
um yes and no what we've noticed so I've
my brother and I we've been in pest
control for over a decade and a piece
and what we've noticed is that anytime
they clear ground for a new neighborhood
we always tend to get increased phone
calls in the periphery of that area
where they've cleared obviously as we're
removing their habitat so yeah we're
going to display some and obviously
force them into where we live and
commensal rabbit rodents excuse me
that's they live with humans
um so yes as we displaced the
populations they'll move in with us and
they'll they're very smart and they'll
adapt to live with us very quickly but
also sanitation is huge the rats as it
was said earlier have been around
forever with us uh you know we can think
back to history some of the major
plagues have been transmitted by them
and so they're very Adept at living with
us so I wouldn't say that the population
growth is fueled rats pretend per se but
I would say that the poor sanitation and
especially with you know garbage removal
and uh just food wastes and uh we get a
lot of clients where they have the bird
seed and they have the the chicken feed
and it's just of course it's easy just
to throw it out and throw the bag and
you'll get it in the morning
um but it's just it's the sanitation so
much as not people don't breed rats they
just
like the same environments that we do
and they eat a lot of the same foods
thank you for your testimony any other
questions representative Murray
I'm sure thank you for my question uh
taking my question thank you for for
testifying and taking my question and
just to be clear is it the rodents
themselves that are transferring the
diseases or is it also fleas and ticks
and things like that that may live on
the rodents that are actually
transmitting some of the diseases that
you mentioned like plagues and other
tick-borne illnesses but my
understanding is that a primary way that
um
tick-borne illness is is transmitted is
is through the fact that they live on
mice and they live on deer
um so I guess to that point is it The
Mouse and the rat themselves or is it
some of these other cohabitors it really
depends on the disease but to your point
yeah a rat doesn't transmit Lyme disease
but a tick that's eaten it can't or
typical in the mice but so depending on
their disease it can be on the other
parasitic or other latch on you know
fleas ticks things like that or there
are some diseases that are transmitted
by the rodents themselves so
pick your problem I guess
thank you
thank you for your testimony any other
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you so much for coming
this afternoon
I'd like to call Joan O'Brien
to
so these are not instances that happen
in New Hampshire this is from out of
state okay thank you just to clarify
that's correct thank you
so my name is Joan O'Brien and I am
representing voices of wildlife in New
Hampshire today
to start citizens of New Hampshire care
deeply about wildlife and that's why
stories of poison owls and Eagles make
the front page and get on the Nightly
News
no one wants to see these animals
suffering
and dying and that's why we're here
appealing to you our elected officials
to do something to make it stop
there's been discussion about cost to
homeowners of one solution versus the
other let's not forget the cost of
losing these animals the cost to New
Hampshire of losing losing these animals
and the cost of the anguish that people
feel when they read a story about how an
owl you know was sick and fell from its
nest dead from poisons people are
foreign
Solutions can be more expensive up front
but if they last you can save money in
in the long run when we arrived in New
Hampshire and bought our home we took
over a contract to have rodenticide put
around our house we thought we better do
that because the previous owners had it
and we didn't want to risk a rodent
infestation
and since then I learned about the
dangers nobody ever said to me that
there was an alternative they would come
they would check they would report that
they'd been feeding in the rodent
stations so I assumed well I've got a
mouse problem so I better keep this
spending the money on this and it's
hundreds of dollars a quarter so you
take that and put it into some you know
upfront solution and then you don't have
to pay you know these these quarterly
bills
um which is what I did I used copper
mesh and I Mouse proofed the house and I
it's well documented that these poisons
have a negative impact on Wildlife we've
gone through all the studies today
they're in your packet one animal nobody
has mentioned I don't believe is the
Northern Harrier which is a state
endangered bird which would also be you
know vulnerable to eating these poisons
and New Hampshire Audubon found just one
nesting site in the whole state for the
northern harrier we don't want to lose
and it's important to point out that
businesses are not required to use these
poisons what they're required to do is
to provide a sanitary environment
and there are safe and effective
Alternatives we've talked about snap
traps and some other things that are
expensive but birth control for rodents
is an up-and-coming area and shows some
promise
on page 35 of the packet you got at the
beginning it lists some Alternatives
including Contra pests which is a form
of birth control
and you can be sure that the pest
control industry is looking into all of
these Alternatives because they have
they're seeing the bands coming and
in addition
birth control is something that you
would have to apply at regular intervals
so there is a chance to to make it into
a profitable business in the same way
that the poisons that are applied at
regular intervals are profitable as and
it's Humane nobody is dying of you know
and I just want to say one last thing is
that British Columbia had a moratorium
on these second generation anticoagulant
regenticides
they they instituted a moratorium for 18
months during which time they did a
study and at the end of that period
which was three days ago
those poisons are now banned in British
Columbia as of as of January 21st so I
think
we would find whatever they found if we
did a study I mean animals are the same
everywhere and the poisons are the same
everywhere so thank you for taking my
testimony
thank you for your testimony I have a
question
um if if we did apply birth control
methods for these rodents wouldn't the
Predators also be ingesting birth
control
chemicals
I I suppose they would and I don't know
about anything about how what would
happen then thank you any other
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today I'd like to call Kurt Ehrenberg
good afternoon this late afternoon
appreciate your time and uh I will be
brief uh I'm Kurt Ehrenberg I'm the
state director for the Humane Society
the United States and our job is to
protect the animals so I'm here
because I think what I've heard is the
science is pretty clear uh these
pesticides damage our wildlife
and that
this bill would
not allow these pesticides to be used
but I have not heard
that that would be all that impactful
in terms of the residential use of these
uh the former types of pesticides
um
please think about
the future of the wildlife of the state
this is an opportunity we've heard that
these have been used for decades since
the 70s or 80s
so we heard the Commissioner of
Agriculture say there is a problem
we heard him say the governor went to
him and said fix this problem
this bill is a fixed to the problem
we support this bill
if the committee in its wisdom thought
there should be some
study that would augment in some way the
pesticide body board that is already
looking at these things clearly
ineffective in my opinion
we've been dealing with these pesticides
getting into our Wildlife for decades
they're not doing anything about it
so we've heard that there is a problem
from the commissioner the governor's
asked him to do something about it we're
asking you to pass this Bill thank you
very much
thank you any questions from the
committee
seeing none I'd also like to call up Ted
Brayton thank you for your testimony Ted
Brayton
put on your microphone there there you
go I thought I saw red from the back of
the room thank you welcome thank you
madam chair members of the committee I'm
Ted Brayton the public policy chair for
the New England Pest Management
Association the trade Association that
represents All The Pest Management
Professionals in New Hampshire and I am
here at today to oppose House Bill 326.
you've already heard from a couple of my
colleagues I could have brought more
today but I wanted to try to minimize
the redundancy in our testimonies for
your time's sake we thank you when I
when I first started in the industry 30
years ago almost all of our rodent calls
came in between September and December
we were told that was because the first
Frost would be taking away their food
sauce and they were coming in looking
for food
that just isn't the case anymore they
are coming in year round and often bring
in their own food supplies like grass
seed bird seed and acorns we now are
getting calls year round and are
actually having more calls for rodents
than ants for the second consecutive
summer
in my experience all types of wildlife
appear to be thriving I never saw a deer
or turkey in the wild when I was a kid I
now see deer and turkeys on the side of
the road on most days and I see red tail
hawks along the highways everywhere I go
in New England
house after house that I am called to I
see blood stains along the edges of the
foundation and a trail of droppings
along the basement cell and this is on
termite inspections where the homeowner
wasn't even aware that the issue they
were living with my fiance and I were
looking at a house last year when she
asked me what's that smell
it was the mouse urine in the basement
insulation rodents are destroying
insulation house wiring jacuzzi motor
wiring wires and cards and stored items
and basements and attics of people's
homes
proponents of bills like House Bill 326
have been led to believe that you can
easily plug a hole or two to solve a
rodent problem in a structure that's
just not the typical case that we find
most homes in New Hampshire are old and
were built to last not built to be
rodent proof down to less than a quarter
of an inch
with low porches ground level decks
cinder block brick and Rubble
foundations dirt floor is an
inaccessible crawl spaces utility line
cutouts and finished basements most
openings aren't accessible even if you
could find them most small business
owners and tenants living in multi-unit
housing have all of these challenges
plus shared utility lines and
Foundations to contend with it is
neither Fair nor necessary to take away
the most efficient cost effective rodent
control materials the second generation
anticoagulant rodenticides and limit
their options to slower less effective
and more expensive options like traps
and first generation rodenticides and
the poor folks in the restaurant
hospitality and tourism Industries most
have barely enough staff to keep their
doors open have you gone to a half empty
restaurant lately only be told it's a 25
minute late
they are also lacking the staff to do
things to help battle rodents and
insects like rotating stock and
improving Sanitation
they are only a couple of negative
reviews away from having to close their
doors permanently let's not make it any
more difficult on these struggling
business owners
the EPA is in the process of finalizing
some new rules regarding sjr's
that will increase training requirements
and restrictions on licensed structural
applicators like ourselves
that apply over 90 percent of our
rodenticides inside the structures not
out and near the fields in the woods
they are also severely restricting
rodentside access to homeowners for
agricultural applications where I would
think
the intersection of wildlife is much
more likely to be happening
I ask that you not get ahead of the
science New Hampshire and continue to
leave the pesticide regulations to the
EPA and the division of pest control
within the department of agricultural
markets and food
as for an update from California I have
several colleagues in California I
believe this rule has been in place for
about a year and what they tell me is in
the inner cities the calls are up the
costs are doing business in the inner
cities are up and in the affluent
neighborhoods where the houses are
starting off in a better place and the
homeowners can afford more exclusion
they were more available for providing
additional sanitation and can afford the
more frequent visits required with
trapping and first generation
rosenthocytes those folks are doing okay
but the inner city the cost calls are up
I thank you for allowing the time today
to voice my opposition the house bill
326 I have also submitted written
testimony and available for any of your
questions
thank you sir
representative knabb
thank you madam chair I'm not sure
you'll have the answer to this but a few
people have mentioned the EPA regulation
so I'm going to try you
um are there other recommendations
outside of the two that have been
mentioned by a couple of people
collecting the dead carcasses and using
boxes because it seems like those don't
go that far to address the issue here
a lot of that is already Incorporated in
the present requirements in labels so
what they're looking at specifically is
some additional requirements on I
believe it's 11 different uh products
for those Products off the top of my
head we're looking at restricted use
which takes it away uh from the
homeowner
is going to increase some licensing
requirements and some training uh credit
hours for folks Like Us in the industry
it's going to require some additional
training meetings and some paperwork
from that
uh we're looking at proposed regulations
for protective personal equipment such
as gloves and
some respirators for tracking powders
and pelletized loose bait that are often
put in rodent Burrows and uh which
doesn't affect us presently they have
some more stringent requirements that
they're proposing in place in areas
where they have documented endangered
species where they are much more uh
restrictive as far as what can be used
how long it can it can go out and then
regular
and obviously that's the bulk of it
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you very much for your time today
I actually have an extra question for uh
Mr Russo
and his colleague
and that is just a personal uh you know
question with regard to chemicals that
are have been used or the chemicals that
we're talking about
I'm wondering is there any kind of
chemical that could be combined with
these rodenticides that would result in
the rodent
being
unpalatable
do you know of anything like that great
question
yeah I'm not aware of anything like that
they have Incorporated uh
the ability to track animals using
luminescence so when an animal ingests
the product you can track their feces
and their trails and find out where they
go to be more efficient at uh at
Exterminating them or trapping them or
baiting for them but as far as making
them less palatable I'm not I'm not
aware of anything like that okay thank
you
any other questions for Mr Russo while
he's here yeah
representative Potenza I'm so glad she
brought you back up
so
um I'm for of course less government all
of that I don't want encroachment on
businesses that's you know that's my
core but when listening to all this
testimony it just seems to me I think
that the bill could be written so much
better but why isn't it why can't it be
for the state for example because this
is really focused on the state which of
course will impact businesses as well
why couldn't you use all of those other
options and have literally the poison be
the last resort especially in the cities
so if you're talking about you said
there's a it's a problem all over why
aren't we focusing like in Manchester
for example if we're in you know if
we're in specifically urban areas why
can't we do
um you know the electric shock why can't
we do I know New York City did I think
they did cats at one point but I'm not
I'm not saying we throw a whole bunch of
cats in the city but I just don't
understand why we couldn't have a a
pecking order in a sense of what we're
using in The Last Resort be the poison
and
you know I don't know if anybody else on
this committee we had a house when
um we lived in Concord at the time in in
my kids were little they were they were
two and three and there was a mouse
problem it was pretty much a brand new
house and it was ridiculous they left
the garage open all the time we went
through every single
um Avenue to get rid of those mice and
those black boxes that were outside the
glue traps everything you could possibly
have snap traps I didn't like those at
all of course because I had little
children and the only thing that worked
were the no kill traps with a little bit
of peanut butter in it that's what
worked we tried everything and the other
thing that is so unbelievable that we
did in our home was we used foam
insulation we we did all of that first
and that was really unbelievable too
making sure that they're not coming in
I mean we've got a surplus in the state
representative I'm sorry do you have a
question I know so I'm just saying isn't
there a way that we can get parties to
the table and and have a solution on
this bill that makes more sense that I
don't know not just a study committee
we've got a surplus of money
if it's going to cost more to in on the
out front why can't we make that happen
and save our lives at the same time yeah
it's a great question I think that with
um
population controls there's a number of
variables in your Urban environment is
going to be different than Rural and
suburb and so the approach can be
different and I think what we heard
today from The Pest Control folks is if
there's an infestation the the the the
non-chemical methods are really a real
you know challenge to make that work
um integrated Pest Management is
something we always include in our
training and that that somewhat
um identify as you try everything before
you get to the chemical but but not
always it'll come down to the the level
of the population but but that and we've
been you know that's been a topic for
for many years and uh
um it just it seems like we're
um as far as how do you how do you you
know how do you mandate you know you use
the snap trap before the chemical I
don't I don't know how you'd approach
that and I don't know if I'd even
recommend that depends I think it comes
down to the variables and the
infestation levels
we have a question from representative
Bixby yes uh one of the other people
testifying mentioned the development of
uh birth control which could be uh
baited to the uh for rodents uh are you
aware of any developments in that and
does that seem to have a promise on the
horizon
yeah we we've um I think the closest
um
municipality I can think of that really
instituted the birth control concept was
Somerville Massachusetts and we took in
a
um a presentation of two or three years
back now
um in regards to that but I couldn't I
couldn't answer how how successful they
are with that with that program of
course it doesn't um terminate the
population it just um it drops the
population that that's the that's the uh
concept behind it is to limit the
numbers
any other questions
representative germanna thank you madam
chair uh and so would you find it useful
as I'm looking through the
um the membership of the pest control
board uh it seems that one piece that
and I'm skimming back through it again
now uh this seems to be missing we've
had some some testimony here from the
wildlife rehabilitators uh do you think
that that is an important piece of the
equation for the board to be able to
have to get some more data around the
impact of uh these pesticides
particularly in Wildlife which I know is
separate from say more urban areas but
that does seem to be a piece that's
missing from representation on the board
the um Fish and Game component on the
board
um and I can't speak for other agencies
but but during the the discourse of of
of the car of the topic it would be more
than likely that fish and game would say
you know what whether what are we
hearing from the wildlife rehab centers
and I think that does need to play into
the input how the board wants to um
engage that
um they could either have a work group
like was discussed or they could ask the
rehab centers if they'd be comfortable
sharing their information
um and maybe have a few meetings
throughout the year where it includes
that group as well as maybe a
subcommittee of the board the boy
historically has been very good at
rooting out
um these these types of challenges
um but I think it would be helpful to
have that input from the wildlife rehab
folks and there was one other was
mentioned was that the UNH um yeah and
and that one is somewhat of an
embarrassment to me that that uh that we
don't have that we didn't have that
immediate conversation with UNH lab we
should have I don't know how that
dropped off the plate but uh the
information that they collected in
regards to the studies that they've done
with with rodenticides those two pieces
the the lab and the wildlife rehab would
be really helpful to this discussion for
sure
thank you uh representative Bixby so um
it was mentioned that uh you know there
were some people mentioned a preference
for the us as legislators to get the
working group going uh other people
mentioned the preference for the working
group to be initiated by the board of
pest control pesticide control one of
the issues that I'm looking at is that
this is an early bill so we need to act
on it pretty soon and it's I think it's
going to be before I think we may need
to uh have the action out of this
committee before your next meeting and
uh which means that
um just in terms of balancing the the
timing on that's a little bit of a
challenge uh would you if we chose to uh
put this in as a bill would you be
profoundly offended by that
would I be offended if if the bill were
uh we put in a bill to make that to make
a working group oh I see my Audubon
um
it's going to happen there'll be
there'll be an action by the board you
know whether whatever they determine as
far as the work group itself and as I
mentioned the board meeting is coming up
on February 6th
and they're aware of what's going on
here and and they'll they'll probably
want to include that information from
the other groups I mean that's how they
go about their businesses they they try
to gather as much information as they
can to to to address the concern so I I
yeah I don't I don't know if they'd be
offended I don't know if I could answer
I'm not on the board so uh okay I don't
know yeah thank you uh representative
Murray
thank you madam chair I I did just have
one follow-up question with regard to
sort of the communications between
whether it's UNH Fish and Game
yourselves I know that when study
committees are formed in this body or
there's other working groups that I
oftentimes other departments are carbon
copied on those types of things is that
just is that a best practice thing or is
that something that is outlined in
statute to you all to ensure that that
is facilitated so that nobody's sort of
missing one another in the future that
sort of these communications for studies
like you mentioned with UNH aren't
yeah I'm not quite sure I understand the
question of but typically when a
pesticide issue comes up we are a
notified a study especially within the
state and I'm not I'm not faulting you
know whatever the community how where
the communication breakdown was I think
it was an opportunity that came up there
was some there was some money available
offered to fish and game to to have that
study conducted and I think the lab just
happened to be the best place for the
for the I don't think it was a a
situation where someone just you know
didn't take the time to say oh we got to
pull pesticides in this discussion early
um so no we're not always obligated to
you know whenever we do outside topic
work to immediately contact you know
other agencies we do it as a practice
and I think we're I think we're done
good with it in this state actually
um but that that one fell off the and I
think it fell off the the the the table
because
um someone was trying to do the best
they could they had an opportunity I you
know I really believe that
uh sure representative Murray thank you
very much and and to be clear that's
what I was just trying to make sure that
there wasn't something that needed to be
stipulated so that you you all could
talk to one another or something like
that thank you
representative NAB you have a question
thank you madam chair I just want to
clarify ask we don't have any stats
Authority statutory authority to direct
who if you do a subcommittee to discuss
this as part of the pesticide control
group who's on it
like is there a way for us to say hey
could you make sure you include the
Audubon Society and
you know wildlife rehabilitator
outside of creating a separate working
group that is sort of gonna in a lot of
ways overlap what you're already doing
yeah I don't even think I can I could
answer that about statutory Authority
and and specifics of a work group I
think if you pass a law I mean we have
to abide by but I don't know how that
would work but you're amenable to having
such groups on a subcommittee again I'm
not on the board I would recommend that
to them and then and typically when the
division recommends especially a study
that they're pretty amenable to to to to
to you know bringing that as part of the
discussion and
um earlier a discussion of birds was
mentioned and and we did pull in people
from outside and uh and that's pretty
much standard practice as you go to The
Experts and if the wild life rehab folks
are seeing this on a K on you know on
occasions that they mentioned then you
know I think it's fair game to say what
does that look like you know how many
animals and
um whatever other information they have
so I I can tell you right now I'm going
to say this to the board on February 6.
that we ought to invite you know
wildlife rehab representative in in UNH
lab
um to this discussion and and go from
there
thank you
thank you for your testimony uh and we
are out of pink cards if anybody else
would like to make a
you sir back there please fill out a
pink card and uh
yeah you can fill it in after you
testify but uh
please state your name where are you
from yes thank you I'm Paul dubo Grafton
County New Hampshire fishing game
commissioner I'm on the legislative
subcommittee uh with that group and they
asked me to come today because I'm
actually a wildlife control operator I
don't use these baits I seal up houses
like the guys are talking about the
exclusion process so I'm very familiar
with that
um
my squirrel work does not cover mice I
never give warranty on mice because they
just show up and they continue to show
up
um our our subcommittee uh talked about
this at Great length not quite three
hours but we talked about this at Great
length
um and we chose not to take an issue
aside on it because we're certainly
worried about the chemical traces that
are showing up in the Predators and we
understand the difficulties of
controlling the agricultural pests and
health and safety pests and we went back
and forth on it and decided the division
of pesticides is on a working group with
it already and EPA is working on it so
we'd like to kind of ride it out and see
how it goes before we come back to it
this study from fish and game I'm quite
familiar with it
um the and I apologize Madam chair for
laughing out loud when you asked about
Predator populations because there is a
special interest group in this state
that feels like the foxes are dying off
because the Trappers are over trapping
them and we have a reduction in Trappers
we've had a poor fur trade and so that
study was actually because there was a
good information that there was a
a strain of distemper going through the
fox population so an individual raised
money and the lab at UNH was excited
about having samples and they were
testing for a whole bunch of stuff and
so this these traces of uh
anticoagulants came up kind of as a
sidebar and wasn't really part of the
study they were looking at distemper uh
and and that in the prevalence of it in
Fisher gray fox and red fox and I
actually contributed a few animals to
that study because I'm a chopper so um
that's kind of the background on it it
was kind of a side thing that came up
I don't know if fishing game was
officially doing a study it's just that
they're by their biologists had a
relationship with UNH lab and so um
you know and as science goes it was a
one-off you know they you know science
likes to repeat things so it wasn't like
a formal paper it was just a summation
and you'll see in that article that was
provided they found Trace Amounts with
no continued research as to whether or
not it had anything to do with fecundity
or reproductive Behavior or anything
like that so so that was the background
on and that may be why it did not get
transferred over the pesticide board
so that's the background I have for that
thank you so much any questions
no questions
so um thank you for that everybody else
in passing on the foxes being so many
Fox there's a lot of foxes and with all
my sister owns a feed and grain store
and during coven she got sold out of all
the chicken feed the bird feeders I
think during covid we had a lot more
bird feeders come along and our transfer
stations are under staff I think there's
a reason we have a lot of rats and I
don't necessarily know what's because we
don't know so just as a question I had
asked earlier
um have you found that there's a decline
in the Predator population yeah I I
personally have not seen that the way
that the state tracks It Is by Fox is by
fur reports provided by fur Trappers and
the number of fur Trappers have gone
down significantly in the age of fur
Trappers you've got the elderly guys
that do it a little bit and you've got a
lot of young guys that aren't as
experience there's a lot of things in
Dynamics while that why that curve looks
the way it looks so the special interest
groups wants to stop stop trapping foxes
but we see them all around our houses
we've got bird feeders we've got
chickens I mean they're everywhere but
the Trapper's not chasing them like they
used to and that's so that that's a
statement separate from the commission I
mean that's my own kind of experience so
thank you thank you appreciate it any
thank you my name
and um
there is data proving that our predators
are declining and I can get you that
data if you would like that yes okay
and it's it's from the Trapper it's like
that man over there and it's Trapper
data that
predators are declining just because
you're seeing a lot of foxes that's just
antidotal that that isn't proven that
that's not science see in a fox is not
science
and we do have that scientific
information that I will send you okay
yes ma'am um
the other thing I just wanted to say
were a couple of things but let's not
wait too long we waited too long with
gdt we almost lost our Eagles because of
ddg
so let's you know let's do this now
like
um you said let's err on the side of
caution please
and um my story is I get mice all the
time I've lived in Bremen New Hampshire
for 40 years I have an old house so I do
get uh mice and of course I will will
not use poisons but the one year I did
not get mice was the year I had a weasel
now if I had poisons in my house those
poisons would have killed that weasel
and then I still would have the mice
so that's the Predator is the best
population controller of mice and rats
not poisons
and I have I also I just got chickens
but you know so I don't want any weasels
anymore
I feel you I just lost two of myself
yeah so um but the thing the thing is I
want to use poisons either you know I
don't want my chickens to get poised
thank you ma'am would you please fill
out a pink card anybody have any
questions nope thank you anybody else
wish to speak sir
please state your name where you're from
and when you're done fill out a pink
card absolutely uh Madam chair and uh
and committee thank you uh for hearing
all of this today my name is Jeff
Traynor I am a pest control business
owner from the southern portion of the
state I reside in the town of Mount
Vernon
um I've already submitted written
testimony to you guys uh I believe
yesterday so I'll keep my points brief
because I'm sure everyone wants to get
out of here I wasn't even going to
testify but I just wanted to round some
things out that I've heard while sitting
here today when I first heard this
legislation was coming the first thing
that came to mind after 20 years of
doing rodent control was do you want
typhus because this is a good way to get
typhus we need to control our rodent
populations I have a very unique
position here because in addition to
being a pest control professional I've
also worked voluntarily as a citizen
with the New Hampshire Fish and Game
department as a Trapper procuring and
submitting carcasses from some of those
animals
um that subsequently tested for these
materials now again I could get into the
Dynamics of Road and control and the
importance of it but I just wanted to
emphasize that one of my first rat calls
was about 20 minutes from this building
and it was such an impactful infestation
that the rats were actually nesting in a
baby crib mattress while the child was
sleeping there oh dear and again my my
position in my job is not Glamorous by
any means there's no joy in doing Pest
Control it's it pays the bills but it's
certainly not the most glamorous uh job
but the point I want to make with
bringing that example up is uh the
individual that lived in that house was
attempting non-poison attempts for
months and months before it got to that
point where the state actually had to
come in and mandate that they get some
kind of professional Pest Control to
deal with the situation
uh chemical use is important when
properly regulated and I just wanted to
emphasize today with all of you with
everything that you've heard from both
sides I think anyone who supports this
bill is coming with absolute good
intentions we can't have chemicals
getting into our environment it's very
important to keep our environment
pristine and clean but we also have to
not rush to judgment and sacrifice the
importance of Public Health for
ourselves in addition to our environment
I think an incredibly good compromise
that has been brought up here today
would be an amendment to this bill to
remove second generation anticoagulants
from the hands of the layperson who does
not know how to use them all of you can
pull up your smartphones right now jump
on Amazon and order a five gallon pail
of brotifycume you don't need a license
to do it you don't need a license to
apply it you don't need any kind of
Regulation from the state as long as
you've got money in your bank account
you can buy as much as you want and you
can distribute it on your property
however you see fit whether it's in
accordance with the label or not
meanwhile I myself am required to have
continued education to ensure that I'm
using these materials properly there are
agents from the pesticide board that are
actively out looking for lettered
Vehicles pest control companies to
ensure that they're following
regulations we are required to follow
label directions when using these
materials we are using these materials
in a locked bait station some are metal
some are plastic the bait blocks are
placed on rods inside of these bait
stations to ensure that other animals
such as raccoons and other creatures
can't pull them out so essentially it's
rodents and rodent-sized animals that
are accessing them
so the point I'm trying to make is that
the licensed applicator in the state of
New Hampshire is already heavily
regulated we're not out there winging
blocks bait around to just kill whatever
we can kill we're here for a public
health situation to address rodents
accordingly
um and I would just hope that there's
some Credence given to that aspect for
anyone who may be on the fence with
wanting to proceed with moving this bill
along and as it's currently written I
would I would implore you all to put a
contingency in there to exempt licensed
applicators from this ban but I do feel
strongly personally that something has
to be done about the immense access to
the layperson unregulated to all of
these chemicals not just second gen's uh
and I'll wrap it up there thank you sir
do you have written testimony at all did
you send any in I did I submitted uh
written testimony via email uh I believe
to your email uh Vice chair as well as
uh the committee I believe yesterday or
Sunday evening thank you that's helpful
any questions for Mr trainer
uh representative Potenza
um first comment I just I really
appreciate your testimony I think it was
um exactly kind of what I've been
waiting to hear
um so
the bait boxes
is there a way that those animals that
are you know they eat and they're off is
there a is there some other way to keep
them so they're not because that's
really the problem right is because
that's when an owl or another Predator
is going to Hawk whatever now they're
just going to take them so
I would say
I'm not sure if this will answer your
question or not but I'll see
um there are regulations on the label as
to how much we can put
in each one of those bait boxes for
example if I'm controlling mice all of
these rodenticides go by body weight so
if I am there to address a mouse issue
I'm using far less bait than I would for
say a rat
in that regard so I would say that we're
mandated professionally to limit the
amounts that we are putting out each one
of those bait boxes have to be placed a
certain distance apart per EPA and
manufacture regulations so I I would say
that we are reducing the odds I I can
never tell you that it can't happen it
can it clearly is but the point being
that in a professional standpoint
there's far more regulation on how we
are Distributing that material and where
it's ending up as opposed to someone
that can buy the same exact bucket that
sits on my truck and let's face it I'm a
dad first thing I do when I get a new
stereo is throw away the the directions
and do it myself I'm not reading
instructions it's fine for a stereo not
so great for hazardous chemicals and the
fact that these things are just readily
available to the public who has no
experience or no regard unbeknownst to
them
um I think is is the bigger concern so I
guess to answer your question we're
regulated in how we're putting that
stuff out to minimum demise
the odds of that material getting out
additionally my company we mandate uh
with all my technicians and myself
carcass cleanup so when we go back to a
rad infestation if we find signs of of
of dead animals or we visually see dead
animals we are picking them up and
disposing them accordingly in a bucket
and then in a dumpster so that we don't
have any contamination issues
thank you
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony this afternoon anyone else
okay I think that we have
talked this enough today
I appreciate everybody's time and
attention and I will call this hearing
closed